the daily caller
has filed a lawsuit because lori
lightfoot democrat mayor of chicago was
banning white people from doing
interviews
and while maybe not the biggest story of
the day because you know joe biden is
going to be printing
six trillion dollars or he's proposing a
six trillion dollar spending budget
which will
shatter records not seen since world war
ii apparently
uh this is fighting back this is uh
organizations saying we're not going to
stand up
we're not going to stand and just take
this racism and we're going to push back
so i think it's something really
important we should talk about and it's
direct ramification of this
just fringe ideology that wants to
create racial segregation but we do have
a lot to talk about in terms of
as we always do democrat policies
because we're learning from many of
these republican governors their
economies are doing pretty
pretty they're going pretty well i mean
in south dakota for instance christy
gnomes bragging about how their economy
has actually improved they never had a
lockdown
then you look at the democrat cities and
it's really really bad the story is
coming out talking about the homeless
crisis they're calling it
a constant estate of emergency
california venice it is just a very
serious homeless problem new york saying
the exact same thing
it didn't work whatever it is they did
didn't work and clearly in new york
cuomo killed all those people
so we know yeah it didn't work and once
again republicans are gloating because
things are going well for them
and now we're learning that many people
are fleeing democrat cities going to
republican areas so there's a lot we're
gonna have to go through
gas prices skyrocketing people don't
want jobs
but we'll start with uh with fighting
back and pushing back on the woke
racist cult stuff and uh joining uh
joining us today is
lauren chen hello hello thank you so
much for having me again it's good to be
back
do you want to just give a quick
introduction sure so
i am lauren chen the artist formerly
known as roaming millennial if
you've been following me for a while
online and i make videos on the internet
complaining about a variety of different
things
culture politics sometimes movies yeah
we
we we we it's a genre of complaining on
the internet exactly yeah commentary
that's what i like to think of us yeah
ian oh hi tim
ian complains on the internet hello
lauren thank you for having me yes ian
crossland here at ian crossland.net
happy to be back
and sour patch lids pushing the buttons
in the corner for this lovely production
with my pal lauren
before we get started we have a we have
a really great sponsor we have biotrust
mct keto elevate powder this is
medium chain triglycerides they are
creamy and delicious and it's for the
people who are
wanting to do keto doing the keto diet
or just wanting to eat healthier check
this out go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com the link is in
the description
and you can get 51 off while supplies
last
they say that they say the keto diet
works wonders for boosting metabolism
elevating energy and enhancing mental
focus but it's also incredibly difficult
to follow
so now you can get many of the benefits
of elevated ketone levels without doing
keto
and this is the key to uh using this new
keto breakthrough that is four times
better than coconut oil butter or mct's
this is the keto elevate powder in fact
ian puts them in this coffee it is
creamy and delicious it is actually i'm
actually really impressed with this
stuff it's really incredible
i've been i've been trying to get rid of
all that sugar even though i have like a
little soda we got these japanese sodas
with much less sugar
i think i think that's really important
and um i bought a bunch of keto cereal
and
it's all really really good the
technology is really improving on this
stuff so
now i'm super excited we shot tons of
this because i'm going to throw it in
everything i've been you know
and we have the collagen from these guys
too so again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com
and they say you get a 60-day money-back
guarantee
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct in its purest
form
that means it provides very fast and
effective support for enhanced energy
levels
healthy appetite management enhanced
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance
keto elevate is very gentle on your
stomach five grams of the highly sought
after mctc8
per scoop keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date
biotrust has provided over 4.4 million
meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals
this year plus this is the craziest
thing i always read this you get free
vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order
and they have the new e-report it's free
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order so if you're getting serious about
your health then you probably should be
you got to take responsibility for your
health feeling good getting exercise
making your brain sharper and this is
one we can do you can do it so go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com
get your 51 off and thank you to
biotrust for sponsoring the show
and don't forget pop over to timcast.com
become a member
by clicking that big old members only
button and you get access to the
exclusive members
area we're going to have a bonus segment
coming up later tonight so you're not
going to want to miss it
and when you become a member you're
helping us build and do
more and uh we're gonna we're gonna have
to you know take over we're gonna you
know
we're gonna have to build something
bigger than all of these mainstream
media networks as their ratings are in
the gutter
on tv they actually are doing really
really well on youtube and we need to
combat that
so there's a couple other things you can
do first let me just let me just tell
you and you guys are going to be sad
about this
yes cnn gets hundreds of millions of
views per month
we get a tenth of that even even you
know steven crowder
one of the biggest conservative channels
cnn gets five
times his traffic that means that means
you guys need to share this kind of
content you need to take these videos if
you like it
if you believe in it if you're listening
on the podcast word of mouth
because if every single person who
watched shared this podcast we would be
bigger than cnn
overnight so if you want to support us
you can
smash the like button subscribe and if
you're listening on itunes or spotify
leave us a good review
let's jump into this first story you
know it's a tough call like
how how in the weeds is this daily
caller sues chicago mayor for limiting
interviews to people of color basically
anti-white racism that's what tulsi
gabbard said one of the only politicians
with the guts to actually call
out this fringe insanity the hill
reports
the daily caller news foundation and one
of its reporters is suing chicago mayor
lori lightfoot
the lawsuit filed in the u.s district
court for the northern district of
illinois accuses lightfoot
of ignoring an interview request from
thomas kadanachi
a reporter for the publication because
he is not a journalist of color
the suit filed by conservative
government watchdog group judicial watch
claims lightfoot violated
kedanachi's first amendment and equal
protection rights
the mayor's office has not yet filed a
legal response to the suit according to
a federal court electronic records
database
quote the city has not had the
opportunity to review the complaint
and has not yet been served the chicago
department of law said when asked about
the suit
hiddenacci referred questions about the
suit to judicial watch
defendant is aware that plaintiff
kedonachi is not a journalist of color
and defendant has denied plaintiff's
interview request pursuant to her
announcement
that she will only grant interview
requests from journalists of color the
suit states
the lawsuit asks the court to force
lightfoot to give kadanachi an interview
and also pay the plaintiff's attorney's
fees and litigation costs
i think it's a good thing i think this
is the kind of thing that people need to
be doing more of
uh so far it seems like now outside of
the daily caller james o'keefe and
veritas are the only ones who are really
filing these lawsuits
challenging the insanity but they're too
often getting away with this stuff
now i also would like to point out the
absurdity of like if he wins what he
gets to interview
lori lightfoot so she'll just be like
screw you
i guess i'll pay for it why like why
didn't she just say no i don't want to
enter i don't want to talk to that guy
why did that she have to make it about
race on the first place
because she's racist yeah exactly why
did she keep it to herself
she tried to make this whole pr move
where she was like i will only be
interviewing
i don't even think it's just poc i think
it's she said specifically
black and brown or like black and latinx
or whatever i don't think she's
including asia
sorry tim we we won't be interviewing
lori life but she was trying to make it
into this look how progressive thing i
am so that's why she didn't just say no
it's because it was part of a
she was trying to score woke points and
now she's being sued so
you get what you deserve but this is
this this kind of stuff we're seeing in
government is is just
you know i want to talk about this
because we recently saw that other
lawsuit where the guy
he sued biden because biden's doing this
relief program for kovid but not to
white people right
and then there's another program where
farmers can get like a debt repayment
but
not to white people so you know this is
it seems to me they found a way to enact
their
critical race theory agenda without
going through the normal channels
because the normal channels would block
them
if they i mean they're still doing it if
they said we want to take all of the
wealth from white people and give it to
non-white people and create a communist
utopia
and race at the system it's not gonna
fly
but if they say oh you know we're gonna
we're gonna help everyone get their
business up and running
but we're only giving money to you know
certain races then they're doing some
kind of
it's insane ideological manipulation of
the system
for some kind of social outcome well i
mean it and it's systemic racism i
support anyone who's suing
on the grounds that the government is
telling you you aren't eligible for a
certain benefit or
whatever specifically because of your
race and this is exactly what
the left likes to talk about all the
time right systemically racist policies
they talk about things like redlining
and jim crow which yes we're racist but
the answer to balance it out is not you
know just throw in a little bit of
anti-white racism to counteract the
anti-black racism and so then it's
everything's okay it's like no
that's not the answer communism it's
it's it's increasingly i mean you know a
lot of people have mentioned like
cultural marxism and stuff
but i mean you look at what's going on
with the state department they're
putting putting up these flags the
embassies or whatever
blm flags blm flags pride flags i'm like
those flags don't represent the country
it is a a cult ideology is is absolutely
ingrained in our government right now
and uh i don't know how you you you
get that out that's that's an
ideological stink lawsuits is good
filing a suit i don't think you know in
the end him getting an interview really
change anything
but pushing back against the racism is
important well and i think
half of the battle is really just
awareness because for the longest time i
would say at least the past four or five
years this kind of stuff has been
brewing and most people didn't know
about it right the normies the everyday
people who
aren't really politically engaged and if
we look at what's happening with all
these different states banning crt in
schools
lydia and i were talking about this
earlier the only reason why that's
happening
now versus a couple years ago when it
started is because now
parents actually know about it because
they were doing zoom classes from home
with their kids and they were actually
looking over the material maybe for the
first time
so it's like with this lori lightfoot
thing the lawsuit is important because
at least now the people in chicago will
know like hang on my mayor thinks this
is a good idea like well i don't i don't
think anyone's gonna
anyone's gonna care a whole lot i just
think this could set set precedent
there's some pushback but for the
schools
i mean think about what that means for
years for for a generation parents
never paid attention whether you don't
ask your kids what did you learn in
school today yeah
i remember when i came back from school
when i was little kids like what did you
learn i was like i learned about
when i was a little kid my mom she was
she was very progressive for this
generation i come back from school and
she asked me what i learned
and i mentioned something about
christopher columbus you know 1492
sailing the ocean blue
you discovered america my mom was like
there were already people here
and i was like yeah it's like yeah the
native americans i was like yeah she's
like so they discovered america and i
was like oh
did you tell me about leif erikson yep
the vikings that's right
so it's so it's like i never understood
why schools were always lying but
here's here's i guess i'm lucky i have a
parent who asks me what was going on in
school
and then she can give me better
information
today parents don't care they're not
raising their kids and it's insidious
like that it slid in to be honest i
don't know because i haven't been to
school in a while but
i would imagine that it's it's it's slid
into like it's not what they're teaching
it's just part of like
the the base of what's being taught you
know like they'll put it in the book
in the the i don't know i haven't been
to school in a while but i imagine that
it's not like the overt
lesson every time it's just no no it's
worse than that
so i saw this one this one math problem
so remember you used to get the like you
know train leaves
new york traveling at 65 miles an hour
another train leaves traveling yeah
whatever so i saw one where it was like
you know jamal is a black man who gets
stopped by police 17 times in one week
and
rick is a white man who stopped by seven
times what percentage of the police
stops were
yeah yeah no no seriously that's the
kind of stuff so it's it's part of the
ideology it's to have it be every facet
of their
of their understanding of the world i
think
i'm hoping kids reject this kind of
stuff you know because
when i was a little kid i rebelled kids
rebel and i hope hopefully the
institutionalization of
of the cult actually makes younger
people reject it
but imagine how creepy it's going to be
when look man
somebody somebody posted on uh kind of
reddit it was like
a meme where it's like a kid i'm 10
years old and you're like so what it's
like i was born
in 2011 and you're like gross oh man wow
yeah like you're talking to someone who
was born in 2014 and people are like
what year is it wow time flies
yeah so in 20 years from today you're
going to have
people in congress who are raised on all
of this stuff
ingrained in their minds and their
worldview will be
absolute racism well i mean that's why
it's important i think that they're
actually doing something to address it
banning it and i
i was just seeing there was this little
twitter skirmish between you know
michael malus who i'm a huge fan of and
i think kathy young
um there are people arguing that you you
don't really support free speech if you
want to ban crt from schools but it's
like was that kathy young saying that i
think she was on the side of the person
who didn't want it to be banned right
who was saying like well the writer just
sjw's too because they're trying to ban
this
isn't it funny she always does that yeah
i thought so a little bit i've
i've interviewed her before and it was
about something that i was on her side
of but i don't see how you can
compare not wanting to fund what is
obviously an ideological
like bent for young children with
trying to cancel people or being an sjw
when they used to complain about
and they still do especially if you go
on reddit religion in schools right it's
like yes get the ideology out of the
education
now it's the left putting an ideology
into education and
we're still saying no you shouldn't do
that but these people are acting like
that's acceptable that should be done
right and i don't think they see the
difference it's like no one like no one
on the right now
in mainstream is arguing that there
should be a you know
christian funded education mandatory in
all schools
because i think we've you know america
has accepted that they don't want to do
that but when it comes to crt and the
less ideology
for some reason well that should fall
under free speech it's like i know like
you were saying
if we're getting ideology out it should
be all ideologies someone needs to start
the church
of critical theory that way it's oh it's
a religion now like someone filed the
paperwork and now you can't have it in
schools
yeah they don't even bother with trying
to get a ban but a bunch of states are
banning it so i guess
it's a good thing um i don't know i feel
a bit nihilistic on it a bit pessimistic
like oh here we go here we go again it's
just going to keep happening so i felt
last night
if you get to the kids you brainwash the
kids that you can
and then you don't even see the results
for 20 years or 15 years that's the
problem we don't realize the damage
we're doing
no no they they do well yeah they like
it yeah they don't think of it as damage
yeah they think of it as victory winning
change isn't it amazing remember when
that republican lady was like
you know she i'm not gonna quote her she
said something about
that guy from you know germany and how
she she claimed that him going after the
kids was a good tactic but she said in a
very very different way i won't repeat
yeah she said in a very crude way and
like all of a sudden the media erupted
like
how dare you say that about that man
it's like yeah you shouldn't you
shouldn't but
she was talking about how the nazis went
after kids
yeah and indoctrinated kids hitler youth
right and now
it's really funny because uh i said it
yesterday i'll say it again
when people always ask like how did it
get to the point where people were
standing in the streets doing the nazi
salute and i'm like the people are
marching around doing the red salute
right now
like you don't even need to ask the
question just look around you it's
happening
and you know what people always think it
can't happen here and then it does
happen here
it can happen anywhere but it's not
going to be overnight
i don't know about that i used to think
you know slippery slope takes time it's
not going to be overnight look at what
happened with covid
look at how quickly it became the norm
to actually call
the police on your neighbors for having
people over that took a year like less
than a year
my favorite thing was like how quickly
the police started enforcing things that
weren't the law
it's like it's not there's no law saying
you have to you have to stay in your
house
and they're like well the governor said
so i'm like i'm sorry do you follow the
constitution in the law or just like
what the governor tells you to do
right yeah and all of these cops were
just like with smiles on their faces you
know beating and arresting people
there's a video it's really amazing man
reddit is awesome you ever gonna read it
i can't stand it i know that's why it's
awesome it is it's like it's like
it's looking into like the mirror
dimension it's like this parallel
paranoid reality
there was a video where it's a woman
having a breakdown over masks and she's
just screaming like i am done with this
i am done being bullied
the cdc data says and the cop grabs her
and arrests her
and the people are cheering calling her
karen and i'm like uh she was citing cdc
data and the cop arrested her
dude the the younger generation that's
on these platforms
whether it's sock puppets manipulating
them it is becoming
1984 ultra cult authoritarian
it's creepy it is creepy and i even with
the mass thing
we were talking about this earlier i
mentioned online i see people in cities
walking around by themselves wearing
masks and they're not it's not like
there's anyone near them and i asked why
on social media people are doing that
and i had all these people saying well
it's to express my concern for others
because i care
so a i got a lot of people saying it's
to express something meaning that it is
a virtue signal it's a social signal
that you're showing that you care
you saw david hogg right no he tweeted
he didn't want people to think he was a
conservative oh my goodness so he's
wearing a mess because of that
yeah i mean it's a social signaler now
so it's either you're doing this just
for
virtue points or you're we've been so
hyped into this fear this hysteria by
the media that people actually think
it's this deadly
that even if you're not sick the other
person isn't sick you're outside you're
not near each other you could still
spread it what well this is uh uh this
is where it gets
we we you know we we're gonna talk about
a bunch of democrat policy stuff but
let's just let's just let's just go here
okay you guys ready yeah yeah from slate
my husband won't take his mask off even
for sex
uh-oh we're both vaccinated now when
will this stop
that's horrifying so so this is this is
mask derangement syndrome and i i i
blame the media
freaking out so this this guy apparently
maybe this
maybe it's a prank maybe someone wrote a
letter like ha ha i'm gonna send you i
don't know i'm convinced that this
real people exist like this oh yeah yeah
yeah i mean have you seen the videos
that people are screaming about masks
like they
lose their minds it's it's it's just
stay away from the people if you
like if they're you know not doing what
they're supposed to be like if they're
supposed to bring a mask in the store
and they don't want to and they don't
ignore them stay away from them don't go
near them it's the weirdest thing
because if you were worried about
getting sick
why would you go up to the person and
start yelling at him you know what i
mean yeah
so anyway i'm not going to read
everything but this lady is saying that
like
he won't take his mask off at all when
he's eating
she says he pulls it up to expose his
mouth quickly pulls it back down between
bites
while he does not insist i do the same i
can tell it bothers him that i don't
especially because i have now started
going maskless outside per the cdc
guidelines
and plan on restaurant dining inside
soon for a girls night out
she says even during love making
is that what you call it like i don't
know that's what married people call it
no i'm saying like when you got a guy
who's wearing a mask so he can't
no you saw the naked gun when they they
had to use protection when they had sex
oh yeah yeah the foals from full bodies
that was love dude these people have
gone crazy and the thing is there's no
science
behind we always here trust the science
and i think people forget that the mask
was originally if you're sick to prevent
the spread right
no it wasn't oh really because in in
asia oh yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry sorry
you're correct
yeah yes because in in asia that like
for a long time mass culture has been a
thing but it was never just everybody
all the time
if you have a runny nose you think you
might be sick you don't want to spread
it you put your mask on and then i was
going to say it first
fauchi said you don't need to be walking
around with masks
maybe it protects a droplet uh that's
how it you know that's that's it's
factory right
and then and then he flip-flopped and
then everyone needs to wear mass all the
time
and it was really funny because
conservatives in the beginning were the
ones wearing masks yes
yeah i remember that there was one point
i was in la and i had the n95 mask
and those are it protects you from
breathing things in
filters it but then when you breathe out
it just breathes out that's right so it
doesn't protect you from the droplets of
it it doesn't protect others others yeah
but that was the whole point of masks
but people didn't know and didn't care
because they were just seemingly like oh
he's got a mask on well they they then
banned them
and like net gators and all that stuff
but man
is it but it was like the psychology of
it was more important than what they
were actually doing
i just noticed i just got to say you
know i remember when this first was
going down like when everything was
starting
and i had a bunch of people on the right
messaging me like get masks now you're
going to want to wear them
and then it's like this weird thing
started to happen where it started to
reversal
and i'm just like yo that's that's
hardcore tribalism
people were like wear masks then they
were like conservatives all of a sudden
decided not to wear that i don't i don't
think it's tribalism i think it's just
being contrary i think that's all there
is to it good or bad
right no it's true it's tribalism you
think it's tribal
yeah the conservatives were our
anti-establishment and wanted to be
contrarian
yeah so they decided and all of a sudden
they were going to defy the the orders
when the when fauci was saying don't
they were like you're crazy and they
went and bought masks
and then once it switched and all of a
sudden like trump didn't wear masks i
guess all of a sudden everyone's like
it's just the weirdest thing well i mean
i think it's interesting to see how this
has unfolded
with the evolving knowledge we've had
about kobe because i remember when stuff
first started happening
i didn't go out because i was scared you
know my dad's immuno compromise
and things like that and we were getting
crazy footage out of wuhan like people
like collapsing in the streets it was
insane
but then what's weird is that as we
found out more about how
covet spreads and about how lethal it
was and things like that
um you know for a lot of people i think
that would have been reason to kind of
ease up like oh okay it's not as bad as
we were thinking we didn't know but now
we actually have numbers in
but for a lot of people it was the
inverse they actually got more panicked
and that's because the media was
reporting on it more
even though all the data we were coming
in was good news for us
i think it's it's widely tribalist i
mean we heard from david hogg
he was like okay the cdc says if you're
vaccinated you take your mask off
but then people think i'm a conservative
so that's it
it's virtue signaling because they're
the
the the culture war tribes are so
distinct now there's there's people who
are
terrified of being viewed as a member of
the other tribe cnn really has a hand in
causing the fear too
veritas uncovered that guy explaining
that we would put the num the kova death
numbers on the screen
intentionally because it got interesting
it got good rev it got good views it got
clicks it got
it it got good what do you call it when
it rains yeah got good ratings
gangbusters for the ratings gangbusters
have them have them
you know if it bleeds count yeah he was
preg
they were scaring people on purpose for
ratings
and now we're seeing does that work does
that work you like scaring people
well it i mean it worked it works it
gets ratings but it actually destroys
society in the process so like is that
working i don't know
yeah so so so i could say something like
uh oh
viewers there's there's vampires oh no
oh and there's and there's zombies and
werewolves they're everywhere
if they get scared now because people
are scared like like people are scared
of vampires
our ratings are going to go up now yeah
it's possible they'll share the video
if you have connections to government
and you're able to actually hype up
government with your like own reporters
going up to
let's say saki and saying like what are
you doing about the vampire menace
i'm dr fauci and vampires are really bad
so wear your neck gators because they'll
bite your neck
i think um in the 20s wore the worlds
orson welles he had a radio
show and they did this this radio show
called war the worlds where they were
like aliens are attacking and then
people thought it was real so i i've
heard that some people were killing
themselves because they were so
they thought it was the end of the world
but people were like going out in the
street and like looking up in the sky
for the aliens it's an urban legend
it could be israel i don't know i'll
tell you what is real
israel israel well yes no no no no
no no oh look at the chat
a guy and a woman who were about to get
are they married or whatever oh yeah
they're married yeah yeah married
they're they're they're on the verge of
divorce because he won't take his mask
off during sex
and so the lady actually tells her like
the the the prudence or whatever
responds with like
take him to therapy yes and then if he
doesn't respond like
leave him what are you supposed to do
yeah
dude that's creepy no but that's that's
not anything to do with actual kobe like
covet is not the problem here there's
something
underlying that and i think that's it's
so true for all these other
authoritarians who are crazy and
obsessive about this
it's not really about the pandemic
because the numbers don't support it i
think it's
a form of social control it's it's it's
media derangement syndrome but you know
what i find fascinating is that it's
it's
it's a sorting algorithm essentially
right so there are free thinking
independent people who believe in
personal responsibility
these people have politics that vary
from economic left to economic right
so you'll get someone who's like you
know a disfacted liberal intellectual
dark web a moderate or a conservative
but then you have people who just don't
know don't care don't want to know don't
want to care
these are the kind of stories that are
shuffling them into two different groups
one group is a bunch of mindless drones
who believe
insane things trump is a russian agent
and then the other group are people who
are challenging the establishment
now don't get me wrong you got fringe
you know right ring people q
and whatever stuff but that's that's the
minority that's not a that's not a
large faction and these way to
understand it is
the prominent conservative voices or the
prominent anti-woke
or anti-establishment voices are not
fringe
like they're not crazy they're rational
they're fairly moderate on the left the
prominent voices are fringe wacko
conspiracy theorists like
rachel maddow claiming that michelle was
going to shut the [ __ ] up what if russia
shuts the power off to fargo in the
middle of the winter what are we going
to do and
you know donald trump russia and then
they had the guy jonathan chen on msnbc
who was like donald trump may be a
russian asset going back as far as the
80s
that's the mainstream institutionalized
left
what's the worst thing you get a
republican party the republican
leadership
that's an oxymoron they're just like
milk toast mitch mcconnell's like well
i'll barrel speed bump for the democrats
and then you get what marjorie taylor
green that's the worst the republicans
can muster
essentially and what's frustrating is
that it there's no
long-term memory or heck even short-term
term memory when it comes to defining
what is and what is not a conspiracy
theorist i mean we saw this with the
vaccine-covid wuhan lab thing
you know we have screenshots of the
media just ripping apart trump for
saying that it could have come from a
lab and now it's like oh yeah maybe it
did
and it's it's funny how quickly that
narrative changes and it's based on
who's saying it
yeah fauci comes out and he says he's
not entirely convinced
that the the that kovid was uh naturally
occurring
and now all of a sudden all of these
stories are being just
flipped and think about how insane that
is because we'll tell you
headlines change because they realize
they were wrong
that means every link that used the
headline now has the incorrect headline
that doesn't change
you go on reddit and look up the
archives look up the rankings and you'll
see a story that says trump pushes
debunked conspiracy
you click it and then it says you know
update this is actually you know
like actually maybe yeah so you look at
wikipedia
how many articles exist right now
wikipedia that
say things and use those stories as
references that have now been changed
see the wikipedia editors aren't going
to go back to a bunch of these articles
some which may be obscure and change all
them so there you go
the whole system is is fried from this
this insanity
and i don't know i don't know what it is
i can tell you that
we used to have journalists that i guess
competed with each other
but now they all walk in lockstep and
it's all about
social acceptance so you could find
i'll put it this way a good journalist
is always researching conspiracy
theories
because they hear a crazy story did you
hear about government politician who you
know was doing this and that
and that imagine you know you go back to
uh the the
watergate imagine if someone came out
and was like richard nixon is
is doing this that and whatever oh
that's a conspiracy
theory oh you're nuts i'm not gonna
bother investigating that
could you imagine if that's how
journalism was back then at least i did
something about it
well they don't really investigate
things anymore i mean one of the only
investigative journalists
is james o'keefe now it seems like
journalists just go on twitter
retweet each other talk to each other
and there's no actual like
first-hand probing or investigating
unless it's like you know doxxing some
grandma who voted for trump
in 2016 because the russian facebook ads
yeah going to her house
exactly and then james o'keefe is the
one who gets banned because when you
know he does something similar
it's interesting about veritas because i
think
i think james is very obviously
conservative but
it's clear that you know the things he's
active about are much more about honesty
and journalism
and incorporations because he's not
doing stories
for the most part that are that are
benefiting some kind of republican
agenda in terms of taxes or
pro-life it's usually like we caught
someone lying
we got uh facebook's manipulating it
does benefit conservatives because
conservatives are getting censored for
sure
maybe that's just where conservatives
are at right now but
uh you look at vox and the new york
times and
they want a political agenda they want a
hard outcome they they specifically want
what the democrat wants or they're just
willing to say
say whatever they have to say to fit in
with democrats i think it has a lot to
do with social media
i think it has a lot to do with urban
centers
you know monopolizing journalism
basically so the people who work at the
new york times
want to fit in so what do they do
sitting down at the bar
and they're in the back of their
brooklyn you know speak easy whatever
and then one person says something and
the other person just says whatever you
say
tell me what to say and i'll say it
cause i want to fit in the fitting in
things disturbing
it does suck to not fit in especially i
mean ostracization could lead to death
back in the ancient world if you're
thrown out of the city but and
unemployment nowadays
and being cancelled off the internet man
it's pretty rough but still uh you know
falling in line to a corrupt system
seems way more dangerous than losing
access to it i would rather sleep in a
bin
in a dumpster than live on my knees for
these people
yeah you got to at some point why you
know i did that with the entertainment
industry in hollywood it was so gross
i could have been easily a millionaire i
was making you know
good money as a working commercials in
la and just
think think about the the absolute
insanity
that is the policies being pushed by
these democratic politicians
how they keep making things worse what
people
just are scared of of not fitting in so
it's it's absolute mob mentality right
you get
you get the uh story of lynchings you
get the story of people marching with
pitchforks and torches
they get wrapped up in the mob and they
just do what the mob does and this is no
different
the like twitter for instance is it is a
constant mob yeah
it's all mob mentality it's people
piling on so people join in because they
want to fit in and they're scared
so what is up happenings new york city
right it's
it's horrible horrifying yes we have a
story homelessness mental illness crime
is skyrocketing
locals and tourists believe the town has
lost its essence some of these photos i
don't even know if i can show you
because new york is bad
like there's a woman laying a mentally
ill homeless man
is seen laying in the street blocking
traffic in times square whoa
you look at venice there's i mean this
is brutal
constant emergency zone calls for change
mount as homeless encampment fills
venice boardwalk
crime increases imagine after watching
all of this
imagine after watching what happened in
portland with
you know constant riots firebombs people
are like well
you know but i don't want people to
think i'm a trump supporter
so i'll vote for the democrat again yeah
and i think what's really shocking is
that a lot of the people who are in
these areas these urban areas like new
york
they've been there for so long they
think it's normal i remember
last time i was in la i was talking to
someone who was from l.a and she asked
like so are you going to be moving down
here and i said i don't think i could
frankly she's like oh really why not i
was like well there's
you know there's a lot of poverty
there's a lot of crime a lot of
homelessness and she was like what
really
it's like yeah and uh even
just recently i was in new york with uh
sean actual justice warrior and
you know he was driving us through the
city and you know we were asking him so
is this a good area is this a good area
and i remember
like he we would be driving somewhere
and he was like yeah yeah this is a
really nice area and like liam and i
would my husband would like look at each
other and back like it does not look
like a nice
area and that's just i think a lot of
people are desensitized to you know
seeing stuff like we saw a drug deal on
the side of the street biggest rat i've
ever seen in my life
but that's normal for them so for these
people who have been
no defense no a little bit of offense
that's bad
for these people who've been living in
these cities for the past year they're
frogs boiling
they don't realize the temperature is
escalating just every day another
homeless tent every day another crime a
mugging
and now they're used to it and i know
this from experience because you know
living in chicago
i remember when i when i leave chicago
i'm like wow like you know carjackings
and shootings are like a rare thing huh
it's like well not when you're in
chicago it's like every once a month or
at least you hear gunshots going out and
you hear a story about a murder 800
murders
per year so you're getting a couple
murders per day that's that's that's
living life so when you live there
you're desensitized to all this so the
people who are living in new york
and there's crime and there's escalating
mental illness and problems
and benefits are worse the train service
is worse
it's just normal every day they add one
more grain of sand to that heap and
eventually the city's trash and
people just live in it l.a though people
are noticing my friends in l.a are
posting about i'm like dude you'll see
under the underpass there's just like
tents tents way way more i was there in
2010 i was in venice i lived in navy and
pacific right on the beach like a block
from the beach
and they had passed legislation right
around that time that they could no
longer camp overnight
in the parking lot they were like all
bringing their rvs in and just living
there in the parking lot so eventually
they had to leave and come back
uh still pretty rare and it was to the
point where like if you wanted to park
on fifth street in venice and then walk
to the beach
you're better off parking in front of
like some homeless tents because they'll
be like hey and they'll watch your car
for you and you come back and they're
super cool but you know
like anything if it's overpopulated it
can become very very dangerous
so so here's two things are happening
right
we got a bunch of republicans they're
all gloating they're like you know that
you know that gif of uh
who who is it it's the was it the
godfather or whatever yeah where they're
like all laughing and smoking yeah
that's the godfather yeah that's so
that's the republican governors right
now
so we have a story red state governors
tell hannity town hall how harsh
lockdowns in liberal states have turned
democrat voters into republicans
who have fled and are now boosting their
economies cool
the democrats i think i can only imagine
want to destroy their cities
well it's hard to imagine people who are
in these cities and who see
everything getting worse like you know
the economy crime and all that stuff
and these places that have been in under
the same control for decades if not
generations
and it's like if you look at the state
of things now who do you have to blame
right i mean it's been the same people
in power so if you're one of those
residents and you're still voting for
those same people
i mean i've got a question like why
right that's insanity just doing the
same thing keeping the same party same
people in power and expecting it to be
different
um i i kind of like i forget who it was
maybe kanye when it was talking about
like
blexit and voting for trump it's like
what do you have to lose
by trying something different if you're
in one of those situations where
you know like baltimore or detroit
you've kind of been sold out and just
completely forgotten about why not at
least try to change stuff up
democracy doesn't work does it you know
my thoughts on this
my thoughts are i prefer individual
liberty
over democracy and they're not always in
opposition to each other but they are
not synonymous like i think
you know democrats often paint them as
being and i do
you know service guarantees citizenship
i think there's
better metrics of measuring the
effectiveness and fairness of government
rather than
everybody gets a yeah so
the the democrat democratic party is
literally becoming the democratic party
and the republican party is literally
becoming the republican party it's a bit
simplistic right now
but uh republicans like republicanism
where you have states and you have
these jurisdictions and you can live in
your state and have your rights
protected and the federal government you
know provides for the common defense and
things like that
and then you have the democratic party
which wants everyone to vote all the
time no matter how old you are
and then just get a majority you know
rule on things
the ancient greeks had two parties
primarily the democracy party and the
oligarchy party
and uh it seems like we might still have
that with the democrats and the
republicans although
they're both a little more like it's all
funneling through a republic now
there is no like mob rule but we still
have like no it's all right and the
oligarchs it's all mob rule what do you
mean well we have the republic in the
senate basically is supposed to like
be a stop gap to the mob rule and say
yeah and and that's true that does it
the democrats complain about it they're
like why do 16 of the population
have 50 percent of the say or whatever
yeah they talk about the senate and the
electoral college not being democratic
as if that's a fault rather than
the point of right system yeah they say
like did you know this it's like
yeah that's why it was created that way
it's to temper mob rule and
you know just the idea they talk about
things like they'll have polls like
this many people think it's unacceptable
to have hate speech yet
it's allowed or you know this many
people think we should have uh socialist
policies like i don't care what
how many other people support taking
away my rights they're my rights you
can't just take them away no matter how
many people are in favor of it
well that's what the guns are for yes
yeah and and
they don't understand that either you
know what it is it really is a sorting
algorithm where you've got people who
just don't know don't care and the
people who do
that's really it they think they know
and care
but if that were true they'd actually i
don't know like fact check some of the
things they read but they don't
conservatives do conservatives
constantly are are reading other sources
and it's not perfect they're not always
correct but as i mentioned
fairly often there's that one study i
think i think it was pew
republicans get around a third of their
news from liberal sources
because they're comparing and
contrasting liberals don't
i think the uh uh jonathan heights
research and moral foundations plays
into this as well
the the left liberals only care about
care and fairness they only have two
moral foundations republicans have six
initially it was five and others six so
libertarians have one
no it's true it's true they have one
liberty that's it it's amazing so you
can take these tests
and they tell you if you're a liberal
conservative or libertarian
libertarians don't care about anything
so long as it's liberty based
makes sense yeah so there's like some
really creepy questions in these in
these
in these tests but republicans tend to
have
every moral foundation which includes uh
purity
uh loyalty authority care fairness and
uh
let's say liberty no liberty i think
that's a six i can't remember
and the left is only care and fairness
what ends up happening then is
i could you go to someone and say hey i
propose
this policy and the only thing the left
cares about is
is it fair or caring about someone
that's why you see democrats literally
be like it's racist it's racist it's
racist
because that strikes at care and
fairness it's not fair racism is not
fair and then you go to conservatives
and they care about
loyalty supporting those who supported
you back the blue
authority you know also back the blue
purity
is you know purity isn't interesting
yeah like family
and and maintaining you know tradition
and things like that the life doesn't
care about any of that this is my
problem with fairness
this idea of fairness if there's two
people and you have one sandwich
what's fair you split it in half and
give each person half what if one of
those people is super hungry
the other one's totally full what's fair
you still split it in half and give them
each
and this guy can't even eat it so he
throws it away or do you give the entire
sandwich to the hungry person
and then you have to make that judgment
call of what's fair and you have to
believe that they're telling the truth
that they're actually hungry
it's simple you take the sandwich for
yourself and you kill both
that's communism fairness no but that's
and communism is the most fair right
well usually
and that's a great point when it also
comes to things like wealth
redistribution like
the communism um is it fair and i think
the answer is no but
is it fair that someone who works all
day uh
gets the same amount of money as someone
who didn't work at all like is
is that fair i would say no and there's
the sense of like
almost equity that they equate with
fairness and they equate that with
justice but i don't think that's
fairness at all i think we have
different definitions of what's rare
except like when it's in a family and
it's like a young kid it doesn't can't
work and then the parent does all the
work and provides equal for everybody
but i think there are people who are
communist and socialists who sees
who see everybody who isn't willing to
work or incapable as
as a child and we even saw that as like
one of the drafts of the green new deal
that even people who
did not want to work would be provided
for this is this is here's the
philosophical question
ian if you saw a beautiful
rare butterfly flapping around doing its
thing and then it got stuck in a
spider's web
would you free it no why not
uh i don't know it's not really my place
would you free it
no i don't like bugs you know i don't
care if it's a butterfly
yeah the trash take care of the trash i
wouldn't i just got to eat yes
that's this is just this what i might
who do i come down the spider or the
body if you were caught in a big spider
web
i would for you right because unless it
was like a lord of the rings yeah
which case no but you can use the uh
what is that
the light of uh of course yeah
the last light of the elves or whatever
that's what i would do yeah yeah there
you go and then
you'd scare the spider away i'd cut it
away and i'd scream yeah pull you down
and carry off on my shoulder
it's interesting so i went out and i
gathered a bunch of cicadas right
because they're everywhere and i just
like attendance had 40 of them and just
dumped them in the chicken city
and the chickens just run up and start
just mashing their faces into them and
they're eating them like crazy
and i thought about like how brutal it
was that these things spend their lives
17 years 17 years of their lives
growing and getting ready to just get
that chance to reproduce and i took that
away from them
i do think however i'm helping because
the smart cicadas
when they when i got close would fly
away yeah and the dumb ones
that's evolution that's right yeah
you're contributing the gene pool well
that's kind of scary because then you're
contributing to some sort of like super
security actually part of the
antibiotics it means that the next
next round of cicadas will avoid people
i don't know well maybe avoid them to
the point where you can't hear them that
would be nice right no they're too loud
anyway anyway the point is this is an
important philosophical question because
a lot of people who only care about care
and fairness would be like oh you've got
to free the butterfly
because butterflies are pretty and
spiders are gross and nasty ew icky
so it's a very childish way of looking
at things sure i mean
spiders i actually like spiders for
better than butterflies almost soup i
would catch the butterfly and throw it
in the spider oh oh
okay i'm kidding it seems like
superficial like this idea of fairness
i mean obviously if someone's starving
it's not
superficial but it kind of is i mean
it's not
obviously because if it when it comes to
the human's life and a human's death
that's not superficial let's let's stop
for a second
you mentioned the sandwich thing right
yeah all right so one person's starving
and one person's not starving
why is the person starving exactly so so
what if the person's starving because
he's been sleeping all day
right and he doesn't work and he's a
misanthrope and the other guy who's not
starving
made the sandwich and he's not starving
because he makes sandwiches
and then what you take it away from him
and give to somebody who's not
contributing
this is the big challenge we face
because as you mentioned ian you would
save me from the giant spider i would
bless your heart uh however there's big
questions about that because
humans obviously want to save humans
because we're all humans we care about
each other
but then our natural tendency to save
each other results in people who are
a drain in the system being saved it's
really interesting i was talking
dysgenics at the yeah
yeah i was talking to i can't remember
who it might have been daniel about
chickens
yes and i think he was mentioning that
the roosters kill the baby roosters
yeah he's the expert yeah yeah he was
saying like they cull the weak wow if
the rooster sees a weak chick it'll just
mutilate it metal yeah super metal and
it's like because the idea is it's
trying to make sure that the flock stays
strong
we don't do that anymore we cuddle of
the week anymore yes well i mean like
yes
well look at sparta war i mean just in
general
we didn't have the social systems to
take care of people the way that we did
i mean also we didn't have the medicine
so it's like you know darwinism
if you screwed up you're going to die
but now medicine and technology and
society in general has advanced to the
point where we are able to keep the
people who would have been killed off
long ago just
around idiocracy yes so you you guys
have seen idiocracy right only parts of
it
so mike judge genius it's uh it's where
they state in the beginning of the movie
it used to be the strongest would
survive
but because of human technology now
those uh who reproduced the most were
being rewarded by evolution
and i think what he missed in that sort
of i mean obviously the idea is that
stupid people reproduce more than the
smartest which is true
but what he missed also was just in
general
people with a variety of ailments and
weaknesses
and you know i mean no disrespect
because i mean people want to live you
know i mean i get that
uh we're humans we care about each other
so
that's that's a really that's a very
important philosophical question that
gets it
into a very into very dangerous
territory but i think so long as you
maintain libertarian values and just say
look i'll do my thing you do yours
we're probably better off but there's a
very deep philosophical question there
if you if you see somebody who is like
their leg is broken
and there's like a wolf running towards
them do you say oh well you know the
strong must survive
or do you help save the person if the
person's got like a genetic deformity in
their leg and a wolf is running do you
say oh well the strong survive or do you
save the person
humans i think and this is good default
towards saving people and it's
unfortunate for us because
in the long term it's it's will probably
have a negative impact to a certain
degree
well and it's not it's not just that it
is like you were saying about idiocracy
the fact that not only are we trying to
save everybody but
it's almost like the people who are the
smartest and who would have potentially
the most to contribute
they tend toward nihilism nowadays
because
of you know economy politics lack of
spirituality whatever and they're less
likely to reproduce so then that is
dysgenic it's like if you look at
women the more educated a woman is the
less likely she has
she is to have children and the fewer
children she is um so it's
it's not looking great for the long-term
survival of our species
yeah and i think what ends up happening
is you're going to get people who are
very powerful wealthy industrialists
who are going to use their influence in
power to say you know what we're going
to intervene and we're going to force
humans to do something
i mean you look at how we treat hogs and
deer
when they get overpopulated humans have
no problem getting in a helicopter with
some high-powered rifles and then
hunting down those hogs
like that's they do this legit crazy
when there's like an overpopulation of
feral hogs they go and they call them
they do the same thing with deer
we have deer season for a reason too
many of them and then we get turkey
season too many of them
humans nobody culls humans except for
other humans in war
well i mean i i don't want to go down a
whole rabbit hole but
there are people who think that you know
there are a lot of
abortion providers who go to places
specifically like africa
um and you know not just birth control
but actual abortions i mean there's an
argument to be made that is
in in a way especially if you subscribe
to the uh pro-life
mentality that is a form of calling it
you're saying there's too many of you
you can't survive you're breeding at too
fast a rate
we need to nip this in the bud it's
creepy yeah there's no re i
i don't i think humans and it's not just
in like developing countries you can
make the same argument
like the majority of abortion providers
are in
you know lower income neighborhoods yeah
in minority areas in minority areas
that's creepy it's creepy this
conversation's like
so it's impossible and i think humans
are i just screwed basically
what you said was the most one of the
most interesting things i've heard in a
long time is that
we we used the the weak used to die off
young
and so are we the strong would breed and
our evolution was strong and now
the weak are kept around with medicine
and are breeding
and so our our species is potentially
seeing that
side effect now and that results in
fascism and all sorts of crazy
deformities within our race it results
in
strong men authoritarian fascistic
leaders who are like
i'm going to kill these people and
that's that's the creepy thing
i think that's why space travel is
probably our best approach we as humans
we can't tolerate
the the idea of just deciding who gets
to live or die
by some person's choice because an
individual will never be smart enough to
understand
you know a decentralized network is
infinitely better but through technology
more
people are surviving even people who
normally wouldn't
what do we do i think space travel space
colonization rapid acceleration of
technology is probably the best approach
because we certainly want to do
everything to stop fascists but this is
a real philosophical philosophical
challenge
and you'll get the scary thing is people
who don't care about technology
many of these leftists who are saying
space travel is a waste of time bring
the money back to earth because they
don't realize the money was spent here
in the first place because
they're not literally shipping money to
mars like when you hire someone to build
a spaceship you pay them on earth and
then they go and work and they buy food
anyway i i digress
these people are ideologically driven
and it's and it's creepy like when greta
tunberg
i think genuinely she is a a tool of
an authoritarian fascistic ideology
because she said she wanted to shut down
fossil fuels now which would result i
think in like
60 million deaths in a few weeks no joke
because starvation
and all diabetics would immediately die
if we lost
access to refrigeration and electricity
overnight because the shutting down of
coal power plants
hundreds of like i don't know how many
diabetics there are but they they need
insulin to be refrigerated
we had the power go out the other day
refrigerator is gone like food spoils
just like that and so we set the
generator up we have the batteries
and we're hoping to keep our
refrigerator going heaven forbid you
actually rely on that like diabetics do
so when greta tuneburg comes out it's
really fascinating
she's this big climate change activists
a lot of these climate change people are
very much
apocalyptic we've got nine years to
solve this problem
think about how scary that is what
they're really saying
there are too many people they are using
too much and we have nine years to
figure it out
or else what yeah so what's that what
and then they talk about a great reset
changing capitalism well for one thing
i think it's kind of great that people
are adopting van life
like millennials are hopping in vans and
cruising and enjoying life more
and just chilling people for too long
were getting their happiness out of
things
nah man you want to sit on the beach
with the dog and look at the stars
that's that's the way to do it and
that's better for the planet everything
but then when you hear you know you hear
these people like greta tunberg
and it's not just her you know aoc
getting rid of fossil fuels
shutting it all down like that would
kill a lot of people very quickly now
maybe they don't realize that
but somebody certainly does and they're
getting their talking points from
somewhere
maybe it's a natural emergence we see
that we see the crisis
in environmentalism from insect diets to
dead zones in the ocean
to you know massive droughts whatever
you want whatever you want to call it
and then people react and say we must do
something what they're proposing doing
would kill a lot of people no it
definitely is and i think there are
there are people that are
okay with it and there are people that
think it might actually be a good thing
but i think a lot of the
people who are making those decisions
are assuming that they will be
in the class a group of people who will
be saved and who will be in power
controlling everything
do you ever watch that show sliders no
you've seen sliders yeah only a couple
times though i loved it
because you haven't even heard of that
really something yeah it's interesting
or something that might be why i avoid
time travel it's not time travel it's uh
it's from the 90s and it's
jerry o'connell's in it yeah and it's uh
he invents a
well he doesn't really invent it his
alternate reality guy helps him solve it
but he
ends up inventing this a portal gun that
opens up portals other dimensions
so the show is like for the most part
they go they go to a different earth and
things are slightly different
there was one where they go to this they
go to this version of earth
and the atm machines will give you
whatever however much money you want
just prints like
you can walk up to an atm and it'll be
like pick your number and so
they're like all excited and they're
getting thousands of dollars like this
is this is crazy what is this place
and they're spending money and as they
do it people keep saying like
you're i'm you're so amazing thank you
so much and there's like sure
like whatever and they're spending this
money because what it really was was
every dollar was a lottery ticket
for your execution so
in this episode like the world was they
kept the population number down
by giving you the choice to pull money
out of an atm unlimited
but the more you pulled the more likely
you were to get executed
and they celebrated it so it's like you
won the lottery and they're like oh
and then they were like thank you so
much for what you're doing and then
wow yep yeah dystopian cool show
show kind of went off the rails it's
dark what happened to it
i don't know it just got weird i loved
it but i it was like not on a time
time slot i could watch dude that's
awesome that's
that's terrifying but kind of an awesome
way to look at money
like talk about frugality yeah yeah uh i
i'm not a fan of
i guess i guess the thing is you get a
choice you're not a fan of death
lotteries no no i'm not a fan
yeah not a fan of printing massive
amounts of money and hoping that we all
survive
we're in trouble though i think so i i
mean some people say that overpopulation
won't happen
that we're not overpopulated and there
will be like an equilibrium a natural
equilibrium would occur
like the black plague of 1200 well
that's the real
equilibrium that high debt high
population density will
result in some kind of plague or
something i mean we saw copenhagen
but we've also got this technology
you know we prevent these things from
happening we have defeated
much of of the threats against us so
what's going to happen is humans are
going to keep
just expanding and but the technology
also has created ways for us to destroy
ourselves and
mass dose like hiroshima or even
just things like obesity as we've become
more prosperous we're actually now
eating ourselves to death in large
numbers which is i mean you and you see
that in now china
you never used to see you know fat
people in mainland china but now there's
a growing middle class and with that
prosperity comes chubby little
so we're creating a plague which is
called obesity yeah yeah exactly through
our prosperity
so wow is the great reset a good thing
no
why not because the people who are
controlling it are doing it with
nefarious purposes so i'm not i'm not
against the idea of a societal
reset so to speak a changing of the
paradigm or whatever
i agree with michael malus national
divorce some people would call that a
reset but
you know when we talk about the whole
buildback better u.n
agenda whatever if you're into alex
jones i mean that's referring to a
specific
number and group of people with a
specific agenda the great reset is real
the world economic forum has proposed it
they're very woke the davos group wants
these things to happen
these people are very much concerned
about climate change and
very much so they want people to stop
consuming to eat the bugs
and to uh live in vance yeah so this is
this is the interesting thing about the
great reset i see a lot of people say i
will not eat the bugs i will not live in
the pod
i'll eat the bugs i won't live in the
pot yeah there you go oh i'm okay with
the bugs i'll leave the bugs and live in
the pod
i i'm if you don't have to choose the
pod
pod choice yeah yeah they've got a trick
yeah no i mean i think about like i'd
love to just have like a tiny
house like by a river or go fishing and
just
and you know be responsible for myself
and uh
i'd have no issue with eating bugs other
than they have to be farmed properly and
not
really parasites so don't eat bugs off
the ground
the media telling people to eat that's
the craziest thing we bought cricket
powder
oh that's the uh the camera mine's
blinking
shut off because they're not plugged in
yeah okay let me see if i can pull it
let me see if i can do it you guys
thanks continue our conversation so this
is now the uh lauren chen show that's
right
she's taking over okay lauren if you had
to eat a bug what would your
favorite bug be it would be something
crunchy i've thought about this
before because i used to watch you guys
know bear grylls right
he's that adventure guy huge fan of his
and i've watched a lot of shows and i
feel
like you you want to go crunchy not
slimy it stopped beeping
and i also don't get why so many people
when they do like bug eating challenges
or they talk about it they don't cook
the buck i would cook them
like just treat it like regular food
cook it clean
i mean in china they and like thailand
they do like a deep fry thing with bugs
my dad he's had uh like
deep-fried silkworms and i mean that's
like a slimy thing so i still wouldn't
want to do it but i feel like you could
make bugs
palatable oh i'm sure yeah we got
cricket powder yeah tim just got a bunch
of it actually i'll try it i'll try i'm
gonna make some bread with it we're
gonna make cricket bread
it's gonna be a mix because there's not
enough powder to make a big five
five cup loaf and there's no gluten in
it it's just it's just gritty
ground up like a gluten make it sticky
yeah so but we have the high
high high gluten flour so we'll just do
a little bit make it maybe help bond or
something
you can make cookies really easily
because you don't need a lot of uh
cricket cookies yeah
there's a bunch of recipes for that i
tried like a gluten-free muffin one time
and it was like a dandelion like you
know you blow and just like crumbles in
there
yeah you want the gluten if you can have
it i got no problem in bugs
i i i just think when i see the media
it's really creepy when all of these
news outlets pop
up with the same story like go eat the
cicadas and it's like
no no no no did you guys see the story
about the dude who ate the slug and then
got paralyzed and then died
no no rugby player oh don't
eat bugs off the ground man it's like
if you want people are like you can't
eat you there's an article from nbc that
said don't hug you and kiss your
chickens
and i'm like yeah no dog it's okay to
eat the cicadas right
what that's the craziest thing they're
like if you hug and kiss your chickens
you could get salmonella or whatever and
i'm like dude we have chickens yeah i
will pet them
and then i go and i wash yeah yeah well
i think the issue is a lot of people
conflate
nature with safe and healthy which if
you've spent any
number like amount of time in nature you
know it's not the case
yeah i mean yeah i mean i think people
live in this idea we're like yeah you
can just like go into the forest eat
whatever drink from a stream and it's
like
no you can't do that you will die very
quickly if you try
this this is the weirdest thing there's
a lot of there's a lot of contradictory
things i see in in the culture war right
you would think the conservatives would
be the ones
saying to eat the bugs and live in the
pods you know why it's like
heartier survival yeah it's it's tougher
it's more self-reliant it's it's it's
stronger
like the way i look at it eating bugs
i'm like dude i'll eat i'll do what i
have to do to survive
me too i would do well in the apocalypse
i'll eat anything i'm scrappy
yeah exactly grass so i'm sure you can
eat grass you got to boil it
you can season it you can fatigue you're
not working it's a lot it's a lot of
wasted magnesium
i've been down this road let's go down
it again you can boil grass
there's some stuff in it but a human
will not get enough energy out of it so
it's
if you have to you can maybe make a
supplement yeah it's like even with the
same with uh
rabbits i think and there's not enough
fat on them right so it's like
saliva yeah they used to they would know
okay well we need some
need some fat shouldn't conservatives be
the ones who are like
if i had to i will live in the i will
live in a pod not like a government
mandated pod they shove you in
but like you build your own hut in the
middle of this thing i think a lot of
conservatives do have
the equivalent of bug out pods and they
probably do have like the mres which i
make you know you know survival food
which maybe has bug
bug in it probably probably but i think
the idea is that like they don't think
it's necessary and there are these
big government people who are telling
you to live in a pod so they can
live in excess right you know there's a
meme it's really funny they were like
it's a liberal saying we've got 10 years
until climate change destroys the world
and the conservative says so what are
you doing about it and they're like
getting an arts degree living in a big
city and not preparing and trying to get
guns banned
yeah it's like you certainly don't think
the end is nigh
you're saying that i don't know if i
believe you that's that's the funniest
thing
it's like i'm sorry i would never take
the bet
if there was a liberal and a
conservative and it was like okay we're
going to put them both in the woods who
survives i'm like
every every hour of the day every day of
the week i'm betting on the conservative
to survive
yeah even if it's like a 55 year old big
pot-bellied you know old conservative
guy with confederate flag shirt i'd be
like
i still think he's going to win that
guy's going to know how to grow possum
man you get the
liberal guy's going to write a book out
of barker you get the occasional hippie
that eats
like grubs that doesn't eat very much
and it's super skinny
that guy's usually pretty liberal comes
from like eating seeds yeah
yeah doesn't need much energy to survive
so so to be fair
the leftists will uh the average
leftists will probably starve because
they're going to try and take food from
each other
a certain sect of libertarian leftists
will do just fine because they're
probably just sitting you know playing
their guitar like stoned anyway
and they're sharing just eating what
they can eating grubs and bugs
then the conservatives are you know
chopping down the trees
out there well i think a big difference
between who would and would not survive
that also
intersects politically is urban versus
rural
yeah right and that's a big divide
politically urban people tend to be
overwhelmingly leftists
and i mean you can tell in their
policies if you if you look at how
you know they are concerned for things
like overpopulation and climate change
and just pollution in general i'm not
saying that those aren't concerns but i
think
just looking at the environments that
they live in cities that are dirty and
overcrowded
if you go to the country i think you're
much more likely to feel like you are
kind of
living closer to nature and you're just
frankly more likely to have those
survival skills i mean
you have city people who probably i
don't know have never been camping never
made a fire by themselves of course
if if the shiz hit the fan they wouldn't
survive
that is fascinating to think that the
people that live in cities are obsessed
with climate change because they're
breathing in
brake dust and they're causing it yeah
and they're they're affected by it like
people in the country aren't affected by
it yep
so they don't think about it the
pollution in in some of these chinese
cities it's just it's nuts where they
have like the big tv screen that looks
like a sunlight because it's all smog
los angeles smog problem what san
francisco has a small no they have a
poop problem
the people who live in these areas are
like look at all these problems like bro
stop living
in a concrete cubicle in a city that's
covered in poop yeah and it's i mean
it's the same thing with their concerns
about things like wealth inequality and
stuff like that
the the people who are most concerned
with wealth inequality come from l.a and
new york and that's because they are
living in the places with the
millionaires and the homeless people
if you go to the rest of the country not
to say there aren't still rich and poor
people but it's a lot more equitable
it's just these people in these like
urban coastal centers they think their
little bubble is representative of the
entire country peaceful divorce
yes we can all of these cities should be
free and independent and they can form a
city state archipelago alliance yeah
well actually so um one of my friends
he he was saying that he's from
california he doesn't want to give up
california but so his
his solution was not like full
succession but it's like there can be
like little city-state protectorates
within
the greater america and they can have
like they could pay
for uh utilities and like national
defense they did collapse in two seconds
yeah because they survive off stealing
resources la only
la uh i shouldn't say only exist but
mostly exist because they're getting the
colorado river water and if at any point
count like their jurisdictions to the
east of la they could just be like nope
shut it off yes city-states seem to fall
apart with the invention of gunpowder i
don't know exactly when they started
fading away
but i mean the vatican i think still is
a city state well even you have the uae
the united arab emirates with like dubai
and abu dhabi
i mean i'm not super well versed on how
they're doing but i think in essence
they operate similarly to that
it used to be walls would protect the
giant citadel and you couldn't get in
but then the
gunpowder you could break down the walls
then of course air power well fun fact
um quebec city in canada is like the
only walled city in north america
really yeah wow it's like walden but not
the entire city i can't
um i mean at one point it used to be i
don't know if it
is all still up but we we went there for
my birthday a couple years ago
wall street in new york was a big joke
yeah it was the big one back in the day
yeah so i want to go back to this point
uh about you know climate change and
survival and stuff because
when i think about we we just talked a
lot about liberals not being able to
survive the wilderness
which is mostly the truth there's
probably some liberals who you know know
what they're doing i just
make it in a fred what's that oh it's a
show where they take two people and get
them naked and then drop them in the
woods
really it's crazy yeah you get the
occasional liberal dude that just
doesn't eat very much
well i've i've heard people talk about
shows like that and like they've put
vegans on and they end up having to eat
a bug or something just because like
it's easy it's fast you need the protein
did you ever did you ever see that one
show where they have two islands one
with only men and one with only women no
and then like the women start fighting
with each other and they can't get
anything done
like one expedition group gets lost and
starts panicking because they can't find
their way back
and then like meanwhile on the dude
island they have like their own bars
already built and they're like
distilling
alcohol coconuts yeah and then the women
come to the men's islands aren't saying
like give us stuff and give us resources
well that's like i have this
evolutionary theory that is backed up by
nothing
already my opinion but um have you
noticed that women don't
work well together generally there's
like the whole
queen beat lydia probably knows yes
yeah and i think the reason why that is
is because men have an evolutionary
drive to work together for things like
hunting but if you look at traditionally
like back way back before we had like
societies
women did not really have much incentive
to partner with
other women right because your your
child rearing was usually your own
family members
other females you wouldn't share those
responsibilities with females who
weren't related to you
whereas if you were a man you would go
hunting with all the other village men
it's not the same for women
that's a good point yeah so the woman
was looking towards the
the man who was going to kill the bear
and you know bring the food back
and the man was looking for people who
could partner with him to go and bring
the food back right and actually
evolutionary speaking if you're a woman
you do have an incentive to view all
other women as competitors for
your man and his chunk of bear meat i i
agree but from my understanding women
tend to
be more bisexual than men because they
had to cooperate with other women
because of
polygamy you'd have more than one wife
so you needed to cooperate with other
women so i don't know you go either way
on that one but
you're probably right yeah i don't know
like like i said this is not based on
science
like at all just my opinion it's weird
how that manifests in modern politics
so it makes me it reminds me of people
have mentioned the the the rat utopia
experiment i think it was was a mouse
utopia
yeah yeah they gave they they created a
utopia where the where the mice were
free to just do whatever they want they
had unlimited food
and you know but a finite space and then
eventually they reached this
population maximum where they stopped
reproducing
they started becoming more you know
homosexual or like
atypical so like san francisco i
maybe i mean maybe these things are
emerging society because we've reached
the epitome of wealth and survival
yeah that there's so i mean if you think
about it there were reactions to
deviations from social norms that were
very severe like
women who worked were witches and did
math because
women needed to have babies otherwise
you were on the verge of collapse
now we have so much that
we don't need everybody to be having
families technically
like humanity's not going to go extinct
because people aren't having babies in
fact it's the other way around
or even within your own family you no
longer need to have seven in the hopes
that like three or four make it to
adulthood
you can pretty much be guaranteed that
they're all gonna survive so now there's
no
threat to society for deviations of
social norms so people stopped caring
yeah and this is this is another point
i've heard i don't know i i don't know
to the extent of which it's factually
correct ask historian when i was reading
about the end of slavery
notably in the uk it started there
because of industrialization
it wasn't this great moral awakening of
these european
you know countries it was you didn't
need it it was it was actually cheaper
to get the the machine to do it yeah and
so then all of a sudden they were like
people stopped supporting it because it
wasn't benefiting them as much anymore
and as the support faded they just said
okay we're done with it i think the uk
just paid
like they they paid the people who had
slaves that's okay we're done
in the us though it was very different
because it's a very very large country
trying to enforce laws across the whole
country
in the northern areas that were
industrializing they were like nobody
really needs it anymore
so then they start voting against it in
the southern states where it was
less developed they were demanding the
right to keep slaves so the point i'm
trying to make is
don't don't give people credit for
having a great moral awakening
it was just as soon as it doesn't
benefit people anymore
then all of a sudden they're willing to
let go because there's better paths
towards wealth it's kind of creepy if
you think about it
the way humans are yeah i mean and also
we were talking about democracy and
like now that we bring up slavery that
is one of the other reasons why i don't
think democracy is a good
way to judge a society's morality i mean
if you look at
where most of people most of society's
moral compass would have been during the
slavery era
most people were white most people were
fine with it does that mean that it was
therefore moral for people to keep
slaves
i mean right because they were the
minority and everyone else thought it
was fine no it does not
yeah not not cool but it's uh
so many different cultures have
functioned in basically the same way
it's like a human universal
i think people i'm i'm fairly uh i don't
want to say i'm optimistic or personal i
guess i'm very nihilistic or neutral
when it comes to
trusting humans intentions i think
people are very self-interested
yeah yes i think they can have empathy
but i think
like learning about that that's one of
the biggest drivers of ending slavery
was just
they were making money doing other
things so it was not
it was not caring it was a lack of
caring all of a sudden they weren't
threatened to lose their slaves
and they were making money doing other
things so they said i don't care
whatever do whatever you want it was
probably a risk to hold slaves
you know if you could have a machine
that did it for you or you could have
slaves that might end up murdering you
or
running away and causing violence
so there's less of a threat you know
analogy humans change evolution is a
result of necessity for the most part
not because it's morally just
it's just how it's pretty much been
throughout the ages well i mean
interesting
addition to this conversation that could
also apply to automation now
right i mean it's the same thing with
your cashier that you see at the
checkout of a grocery store or at a
restaurant that's why a lot of people
are saying just like maybe they did
slavery industrialization it's cheaper
to automate so now you no longer
have a lot of those like hourly workers
you just have your little self-service
scan thing or kiosk where you put in the
order
yeah nobody wants the work but it's more
than just the kiosks it's
a lot of other the the big problem there
is we're not talking about forced labor
we're talking about
parts of the economy that are being
automated
and then people don't have work can't
get money
this i think is one of the reasons we
see the rise of socialists
this problem emerges where people
through no real fault of their own
there's a lot of people who don't want
to work it's their fault
there's a lot of people who got
automated out of the workplace
and then where they get told learn to
code not automated or even just
technology displace them and they get
told learn to code and it going to work
so what do you do
well we can't just be luddites and
they're like okay we're banning
technology because people need jobs
that's stupid
it's supposed to make things easier but
here's the problem if we start giving
these people money like ubi
what do you tell the farmer who has to
work right
well they the the people who live in the
cities it's it's this way right now
people in new york well at least before
the pandemic
working for media companies are getting
paid 30 40 50 000
to write garbage trash articles about
nonsense meanwhile people are getting
paid
minimum wage to pick fruit on a farm
so how does that make sense by the
left's own standard
they should not be getting that level of
pay for what they do
that's going to be a big problem when we
start when we when we create ubi or if
andrew yang gets his way in new york
city and tries doing some kind of ubi
you mean you're gonna have someone who
lives in new york city of all places one
of the wealthiest place on the planet
getting free money to buy the apples
that i pick for dirt wages i'll just
move to new york city
get free money yeah why bother yeah i
don't like the job economy thing
the the federal reserve's obsessed with
creating job creating employment for
everyone they want you to dig a
hole and they want you to fill the hole
back up and then they're gonna
loan you money for it and then expect
you to pay
pay them back with interest so they keep
everyone busy and you can see as we're
automating that that doesn't work
people don't have things to do and
creating
you know random things that don't
benefit society
doesn't solve that problem well i think
we we saw a lot of that kind of rhetoric
from joe biden's recent like joint
session speech the state of the union
which we're not
calling the state of the union but
anyway um the idea that yeah the
government would just make jobs
for people to have jobs but i think the
whole problem
ultimately is that labor is and
is not a commodity right it's a
commodity in that it responds to supply
and demand
but it's not a commodity in the you know
if you have too many widgets sitting on
the shelves
you just stop producing widgets for a
while and then eventually you'll sell
the ones that were overstocked that's
not true with labor
you have unemployment people get
restless they need to be fed and things
like that and they're riot
and they're right so i think the problem
why this automation is happening at the
rate it is
it's a people are campaigning for high
minimum wages
which just makes automation cheaper and
then b you also have an immigration
system
that is welcoming in low-skilled workers
who are competing
for jobs that really the people who have
those jobs are already in an extremely
vulnerable position so it's just a bad
a bad situation all around maybe we just
need
you know an individual of of of
intelligence and
merit to just rise up naturally and gain
power
through the competitive system maybe
somebody who understands like computers
because of like you know someone who's
like a computer developer of some sort
and then he can start deciding what's
best for us yeah like a technocrat
like a technical maybe a kid by the way
maybe like a like a dictator
oh yeah like a like an artificial intel
no more like bill gates bill gates did i
say that already
like bill gates yeah a doctor but a lot
of medical advice do we need like an ai
that don't
i don't want an ai government but i
would like an ai advisor
for our government no but the thing is
an ai advisor
would be i think completely utilitarian
we would not as human beings be
comfortable with what they recommend or
what it recommends
yeah they'd be like hello ian you must
die today because
it will save three children i disagree
uh maybe we could have like 90 uh
artificial intelligence advisors
this is one of the biggest challenges
with self-driving cars that someone has
to program in the car
if you're driving in your car and an old
lady walks out in front of you
the car has to choose do i crash the car
killing the driver
or hit the old lady lady someone's got
to program that
yeah and those those are deep
philosophical questions that i think
even as humans we don't understand
and we need to have debates about which
we aren't really doing right now we're
kind of just like
kicking the can down the road but i
don't expect a machine to do if you were
driving and the car was like
ian will you die to save her as you're
like hey you're like
i don't have time to think about it
could you could you imagine like so you
mentioned the ai would be utilitarian
but i think it's the only thing it
possibly could be how could there be an
ai that was deontological in that it
would say
catholic a.i i don't know no but but
imagine it's like
it has to save everybody but it's not
possible
yeah so it's like imagine you're in the
scenario where the car is driving
and the old lady let's let's say
something happens through
it's a no fault scenario no one is at
fault just
uh something happens avalanche no no
it's
there's got to be two people that are
one person's gonna it's it's a zero-sum
game where one person lives one person
dies
the a.i if it was deontological it could
not commit an immoral act against any
individual
yeah so it would recognize one person's
gonna die no matter what
i don't know which one so you have to
let both die in that case because
otherwise you'd be making a choice that
would lead to someone else's death
yeah i guess it would let the five
people die on the trolley
yeah exactly instead of the one the
utilitarian would let the one person die
yeah i would let the one person die and
it's like
my husband he's catholic and he studies
philosophy and he often tells me that
i'm
too utilitarian because he is you know
deontological like that whereas i'm i'm
i like to think of it as pragmatism
what's the difference between
deontological and utilitarian oh my gosh
so this is where liam would come in
handy and it's funny because he's
explained this to me so many times but i
tend to tune out when he talks
it's i'll oversimplify it for you spock
is utilitarian
and captain america is a deontologist
it's very simple spock said the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
captain america says we don't trade
lives right yes that is good
deontological is more like the idea that
an immoral act against an individual
like you you you are barred from the
ends do not justify the means
i guess right on which the bad guys tend
to be utilitarian i guess in the
instance of spock he wasn't but that's
i'm not a fan of utilitarianism it's
where like
there's there's the problem with it is
that you start it's it's very much like
the equity argument you start trying to
decide
what about someone is worth more than
something else well i mean
not to bring up the avengers but that's
why thanos
was in favor of the infinity stones just
randomly selecting half the people
because he
believed the world was over or the
universe was overpopulated what an idiot
he was really dumb yeah the book made
him better he he was trying to please a
woman did you read the comments
well he was trying to please exactly
mistress death yeah he wanted it
i like the that's the movie thing is
more appointments right that's the movie
is updated and it was originally
uh yeah he's utilitarian yeah he says
kill half of the universe just to
protect the other half but
and then what a few generations you're
back to where you started it's a
terrible idea
and someone i saw someone else uh
there's a meme where they're like why
didn't he just double the amount of
resources by snapping his fingers
oh yeah cause he's a bad guy question
because he was trying to
i because he wanted a woman mr stefan
here's my issue with the needs of the
money outweigh the needs of the few
you know the equity thing right they say
oh this person is more deserving than
that person for this reason you
mentioned it with the sandwich yes
the child's view the the child who has
no experience no wisdom
sees a hungry person and a well-fed
person and says give the sandwich to the
hungry person
and what the wise person says is well
hold on
why are you why is this person starving
and why is this person well fed
who made the sandwich there's a lot more
questions than just i'm going to give it
to you
so when it comes to utilitarianism
here's
here's here's the version of the trolley
problem i have first
you you know the trolley trolley problem
right there's a trolley going on track
and you have the switch and you have to
decide if it's going to go down
kill one person or go to this track and
kill five or something like that
there's a trolley heading down a track
with five people on it
it will hit and kill all five people you
can pull a lever to switch the track
with only one person on it
the act of switching the lever condemns
the one person who is safe
to begin with would you kill that one
person by your choice
who was safe to save five people so the
darker side of me says
who is that person but and who are the
other five
but i mean just philosophically speaking
i would okay now here's now here's the
bigger question
there's a bunch of iterations of the
trolley problem let's try it let's try
ian what would you do would you let the
trolley kill the five people or would
you choose to kill the person no no if i
had a split second decision i would kill
one instead of five
so that so that means that one person
who would have normally lived you are
choosing to to
kill them to save those five yeah yes
okay now let's say
the one person has the cure for cancer
exactly
and you know it and you know it oh and
he killed that five
you let the five die yeah see that's
where things become problematic with
utilitarianism
you as now let's play another game the
five people
are critical race theorists and the one
person is jordan peterson
oh i love jordan so you're saying the
five have the cancer and the one has the
cure
no no what i'm saying is there's five
prominent critical race theorists and
one prominent
you know anti i feel like i can't answer
this without people calling me a
murderous extremist right because
of and the crazy thing this is what the
government does this is their job okay
okay
who dies let's take it out of american
politics it's uh
there's five supporters of vladimir
putin and no this doesn't this doesn't
work uh yeah wait hold on okay yeah
five supporters of vladimir putin and
one opposition activist who's prominent
save the one you'd save the one so the
issue is
now you're making moral judgments over
whose life is based on your subjective
view of what is right and what is wrong
that's the problem with utilitarianism
and they'll do like
there's you know they'll say like i
don't like saying black and white people
but let's just for whatever reason
there's there's 10 black people that
and by by the numbers say that they make
less money
so but then there's five white people
and the numbers say they make more money
so where are we going to send the money
we're going to send it to these 10 black
people but you find out later these 10
black people have
make way more money than these five-way
people they're just going by the numbers
in the book and making these these or
they're or they're going by
capital gains and not by you know hours
worked but i mean i understand the
criticism that
you through utilitarianism you're
necessarily like putting your
moral values onto the situation but i
guess like in business they say even
making no decision is making a decision
so i my response to that would be that
it's impossible from like an ontological
perspective to avoid that most people
i i think most people say they wouldn't
pull the lever they would ignore it
they don't want anything to do with it
because you are choosing so right now
the five people on the on the track
they're in that circumstance having
nothing to do with you
if you intervene you make the choice to
kill someone
so most people say i wouldn't but it's
essentially whether the ends
justify the means like in in the
scenario
if you kill someone essentially you make
the choice to pull that lever it does
end with five people being alive versus
five people being dead so you both said
you'd pull the lever to save the five
right yeah
what if it's five eighty year olds and
one baby
i pulled a lever or sorry like i killed
the 80 year olds so you don't pull the
lever yeah i don't in that circumstance
you let them die
yeah so that's the problem with
utilitarianism you
have a personal subjective moral view on
who should live or die
and it's something but again i don't
think that's a problem of utilitarianism
versus just
an aspect of any philosophical grounding
it's like it's based on um what do they
call it when like you get
you get the numbers of how many people
live in this demographics it's based on
like demographic
you know book numbers in a book like
they don't know who needs what but
they're giving it to people based on
what they read
i guess like my my view of
utilitarianism is that
you are accepting the fact that losses
or deaths will happen and then you
approach the problem in order to
minimize the losses and maximize the
gain so i approach it almost like
business
so you you guys have seen all the memes
that have popped up about the trolley
yeah yeah my favorite one is it's one
single track with a ton of people
yeah i see that lately and it says you
can stop the trolley at any time but it
would cause a loss of corporate profits
like people are getting run over oh my
gosh it's like that
that's funny because there's
corporations that function that way
like that monsters inc meme like i'd let
a thousand children die before i
let this company burn or go under
whatever
yeah man so these are the these are the
tough questions we're getting into now
with uh technology ai
with the great reset with climate change
with healthcare even
if you're especially canadian or coming
from the nhs system there are
calls that need to be made and like
there's limited resources to go around
yeah i love how these leftists tweet
that there are no there's no such thing
as scarcity
there was a story about some kid in like
alabama or something there he needed
gene therapy that would cure his his
disease and it was like a million
dollars
and the state was like we can't pay that
sorry and then
people were complaining like you have to
pay you otherwise he dies like you have
no choice and they were like it's a
million dollars and they're like what's
the value of a life
and it's like yeah but we don't have it
like we can tax everybody i guess
what's the cost of a human life um
there's there's actual numbers you can
look up in terms of how the market
values human life yep
i think it's like 180 000 something is
what it's worth or what it costs yeah
based on the organs that could be sold
or something yeah
i see that's a tough that's a tough
number to figure out because what what
could they contribute to size society
what are they going to take away from
success that's why i mean like life
insurance proves that not everybody's
life is worth the same because not
everyone's going to get the same payout
if they die also i watch a lot of like
murder crimes like don't get
life insurance if you're on rocky
grounds with your spouse
if you're fighting with your wife and
she says she wants to sign you a new
life insurance policy just yeah be
skeptical but i mean the whole issue of
scarcity is when
like you were saying the left does not
understand and i think that's the reason
why we have so many of these economic
questions
regarding things like minimum wage
regarding healthcare is that they don't
want to accept that scarcity is
a real thing even regarding like the
housing situation yep
yeah you know the the oil and gas
industry in the copper industry
has been holding us back from fusion
generation and like atomic printing and
like a
a land of less scarcity if not total you
know dissolution of scarcity
but and i think the critical theorists
see that and so they they're acting as
if
they've already won applies to
everything yeah every
and it's not yet so so there's massive
scarcity right now
it's severely difficult to get materials
into the middle of the desert right now
maybe that'll change one day but you
know it's really crazy just like
because you mentioned the desert las
vegas is being terraformed
or reclaimed oh i heard that yeah
because they're bringing grass in
and then here's the craziest thing you
know what's changing the landscape of
las vegas more than anything else
human beings go into the bathroom huh
huh fertilizer they fly on planes
and they have water in their systems and
they land
and they deposit water they bring food
in with them
and they bring in more water than they
take out that's interesting it's really
crazy i was reading about it and they
said
food is the biggest contributor to the
the reclamation of las vegas
as well as grass they're shipping in
water they're planting grass the grass
helps retain moisture and they're
turning a desert into
like not desert or whatever interesting
because i think they're they're trying
something along
china's border as well with the gobi
desert to prevent desertification
um they're planting like almost like a
green wall or something to try to
divide it they're doing that in the uh
the southern sahara
yeah they planted all these trees to
stop the desert from spreading we got to
start just doing those projects it's
like we want to go to mars and stuff
that's cool too but let's also like
reclaim all these deserts
yeah that sahara sand is ocean sand they
find seashells and stuff it seems like
it's from the great
the great because you have all the
microorganisms that kind of
oh interesting yeah that's why there's
oil we could put it back in the ocean
that's something i want to do dude the
sahara is
massive i know just dig it off build
drones that can just carry it into the
ocean like
thousands of miles what if like what if
they just
dug like a massive trench from the
middle of sarah all the way to the
western coast and just let the water
flood
like a river yeah probably that'd be
cool beach front
property tell salt water though you
can't really do anything with it maybe
i don't think that's with like within
the capabilities of human beings right
now i mean no
it is but like not within the wild power
that would be a great global human cause
what fix the sahara re-greenify the
sahara because it used to be a like a
jungle like a like a forest with rivers
and
rain it's this the desert spreading so
it's just destroying organic matter and
then
water gets ripped out and can't be held
what's spreading it is it the wind
yeah it like spreads the sand and stuff
like that makes it harder for plants to
grow
and so what's happening in vegas is
humans are rejecting it
humans are like forcing stuff to go
there
we're such a part of our ecosystem like
i was thinking of the animals that eat
the fruit that carried and then they
crap out the seeds
over there and then it plants the tree
and like that's we're like that's us
isn't soil there's like dead stuff isn't
dirt like outside just dead stuff
i think yeah it's like so yeah like
we're just we just live on the on the
on the on the cemeteries of all the
billions of organisms that came before
us all that dirt
yeah i gotta find out cause yeah look at
that before what is dirt i'm pretty sure
it's like
decayed organic matter yeah just like
rots there and then the plants grow out
of it
yeah just the rotting corpses of the
billions of animals and bacteria
and plants and we're walking on top of
it
yeah wow all right let's see it what is
it all right
is dirt dead organic matter dirt is dead
it has none of the minerals nutrients or
living organisms found in soil
it is going to organize the soy system
there is no top soil or hummus or worms
yeah no look up soil's dead and does not
okay i'll look up
what is soil yeah like dirt is different
dirt's like the gritty stuff on the
sidewalk you know what i mean sand yeah
is soil dead so like when you walk out
into like the forest
all the ground is like that's like
decaying organic matter isn't it yeah
because like when the
when the trees fall or went out it just
stays there and then it
decays oh the well-decomposed organic
matter and soil the very dead
is called hum hummus hummus humus
yeah i'm learning new things today i
like i like roasted garlic hummus
okay some use the term humus to describe
all soil organic matter some use it
describe just the part you can't see
without a microscope interesting i don't
know so maybe part of soil is
is humus we are standing on a mass grave
of life
yeah and we don't even realize we don't
care i mean that's also what oil is
that's what's powering
most things for us yup yeah what a crazy
reality
yeah let's read some super chats yes if
you haven't already please my friends
you must smash that like button but
i'm gonna start saying something more
and more often a lot of people say like
what can we do you know
we we believe in the things you guys
talk about and uh we said yesterday with
jack
it really is sharing i mean it is
you can call it a shameless blog like
make sure you share the show but think
about it if people are only getting cnn
how do we beat cnn i mean their ratings
on tv are down but their ratings on
youtube are
are massive if people choose to take
this video and put it on their facebooks
on their twitters
it would be exponential if every day
every single person who watched shared
it would be an exponential growth
bigger than cnn overnight it's really
about your willingness to engage in that
way
and maybe it's not my show but if steven
crowder or
uh project veritas share all of it
and tell other people to share it orange
show or lauren's show what is you're
sitting right here
i'm shouting crowd around yeah all right
thanks uh you can find me on
youtube bit shoot rumble odyssey lauren
chan or at the lauren channel on twitter
instagram i try to be the like the same
username everywhere and on all platforms
i'm so into creating a community or
community in general
with the internet video like like
it's i've got to share yeah yeah yeah
and get
and work together think about this way
the people who share cnn do it
mindlessly yeah they see
don lemon and they're just like they
click in and they post chair that's
crazy to me
how is it that that cnn is able to
muster up more shares on their content
than
the active people who are actually
paying attention and want change to
happen
probably name recognition i think it's
just because there's a lot of regular
normal people who just click the share
on cnn they're not paying attention
well i think it's like it is that name
reckon it's like oh cnn news
share news bart simpson was put in a
remedial classroom and he said
we are so how are we we're supposed to
catch up to them by going slower than
they are
and that's what that and they were
because they were you know yeah so that
means
if we're on a treadmill and we're slowly
moving backwards when we stand still
so he's had to just walk forward we're
staying where we are
meanwhile cnn's got that natural push
youtube puts them on the front page
regular people no cnn they share it cnn
gets put in movies like iron man and
stuff
that means we've got airports we've got
to be running on that treadmill yeah
their treadmill is going
slower because because the algorithm is
sharing it more for them so they don't
have to run as hard as we do
i think i think we're on the on that
path though i think i think cnn's not
long for this uh
because you don't get a visual workout
cnn's treadmill is not moving at all man
they don't even they just stand up
they get hundreds of millions of views
per youtube it's true they're being
they're being propped up
how would their views dipped though
since trump got out only
on um probably yes on youtube but mostly
it's tv ratings
on youtube it's like hundreds of
millions of views hundreds of millions
like four or five times what crowder
gets you know
uh uh six you know five or six times
what we get
the weird thing about youtube news is i
can't tell the difference of what's an
nbc
video what's an msnbc what's a cnn when
i see the thumbnail
i don't know i just see the face and the
words and i
click it or don't well what's annoying
about youtube the way
their news algorithm works is that i
know at least in canada the
authoritative sources are things like
cbc and ctv which no one watches exactly
you'll be on the front page
and you'll see these stories and it'll
be like published five hours ago
2 000 views front page of youtube but
it's like okay well that
that's definitely astroturf like that's
not organic they're showing them
favoritism cnn's main channel just one
of their channels it's 141 million views
in the past 30 days they gain over 100
000 subscribers a month
we're competing with them i wonder what
their marketing budget is like for those
because crazy this timecast marketing
budget is i think
close to zero relatively zero but well
yeah yeah we haven't like
pumped 40. 40 million dollars a year
into marketing or whatever the heck
the only the only commercial we've run
so far is recently on will of the people
the song
for no other reason than vanity i think
let's let's you know i got a song let's
let's
it's made to be listened to so we'll
promote it i think ben uh
and culture daily wire they they push
tons tons good marketing
very good and that has a good return
marketing so we're going to start doing
marketing for sure we're
doing more right now it's just social
media organic growth but that's why it's
like
look at this one thing you can do you
can become a member at timcast.com
because i'll tell you this the money
that we get from timcast.com when you
become a member and that 10
or the 25 or whatever you give goes into
the account for us
it's going towards us hiring more people
doing more shows
and building more and more and more so
it's not just that
you are buying a membership to get
access to exclusives you're actually
buying
the expansion of what we do so if you
like what we do
no like we're not going to be i know i
know it's going to break your heart
again we're not buying an infinity pool
i'm sad tim or
we are going to get a hot tub well now
i'm happy but it's going to be powered
by dogecoin mining i've heard
i'm excited saltwater hot tub i don't
know the plan was to get a bunch of gpus
and have them mine dogecoin so it heats
the water and then you get it
i hear you can get an ozone hot tub the
ozone cleans the water we're going
the hot tub will be the cooling system
yes the hot tub is the coolest
system hey here we go also when you
subscribe to this channel and lauren's
channel
click the bell button yes because then
you'll get notified when the videos go
live and then go to the top url bar
click control click it and then control
c and then go to
instagram and facebook and twitter and
wherever you can just paste it and call
your mom if you haven't talked to her in
a while
let's read some super chats all right
stupid spin videos says
what's the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth
about six to 12 months that's true it's
a good one
dude amc hit what 28 bucks today did you
see that i'm not following it no i hear
cassandra keeps tweeting about it she's
pumped
i bought some amc like literally a very
very small amount
because i like going to the movies and i
thought that they're
like i saw their stock and people were
talking about it i'm like did their
stocks gonna go up when the movies come
back
because they're doing a bunch of
releases only in theaters soon and i'm
like i
dude i loved one of the movies i miss it
yeah it's like what the like
once a week every weekend it's like
let's go to the movies and then we got
for pizza or something
that was it that was the night out and
they got rid of it it was fun and it's
not fun just turning the tv on and
watching hbo max or whatever boring
yeah boring so we have like a big
projector but it's not the same you know
you can see you got some
good popcorn there yeah and and it's
it's i'm only satisfied when i spend 20
dollars on a box of sour pictures it's
true yeah it's got it's got to be
expensive
yeah i like when you go into the movie
when it's light out and then you come
out and it's dark
my dad's he's weird though he'll like
he's like he puts like snacks in my
purse like
you got a smuggler but he's like asian
so they're they're they get increasingly
complex he gave me like sauteed squid
ones
john lee says hey tim i know you are
busy with the other website and stuff
but i just want to ask
is the chicken stream going to be on the
new website and do i need
to pay another membership for the new
website um
timcast.com is there's no that's it if
you remember timcats.com you're good
all the content's going to be there
chicken city is going to be a live
youtube channel
and um we're we're getting a chicken
whisperer to come out
to help us get it set up oh yeah and
then it's just you know we're gonna have
merch so we have seven chickens now we
had six before but
we adopted dorothy she's older and so
there's gonna be she she probably won't
be part of the
of the crew but we're gonna do we're
gonna do merch so there's gonna be like
a picture of
you know like vanessa margaret sarah
they're all they all have names
and there will be shirts designed based
on each individual chicken and then you
can support
those chickens by buying those shirts uh
we were trying to feed team vanessa
dorothy's margaret oh it was margaret
earlier yeah because she wasn't eating
cicadas
yeah but me and the cat were sitting
right next to the chicken and the
chicken was flipping out so i think that
was i took buck away so when i feed her
whenever i throw in the cicadas margaret
won't she just looks at him and like
pecks him a little and like gets
gets scared she used to be the biggest
one too and then dorothy who's older
than everyone
just one shots all the cicadas just like
oh
like it's like homer eating donuts so we
got to like push her back like dude you
had 12 already you're gonna get sick
let the other chickens have have a go at
it but we'll be getting it up soon
it's uh there's there's challenges in
like we're we'll use gopros because
they're waterproof ish but they stop to
be plugged in all the time
so we'll figure it out but um we'll try
and get it set up i think i think in
this next weekend i think we should be
getting it set up
and it's going to be a 24 7 live stream
we need to hire a composer we need
someone who writes music
so that we can get about a couple hours
worth of lo-fi hip-hop beats
to watch chicken city too yeah and then
just have the stream going
all right omg puppy says check out the
ufo debunking videos on youtube
david falch shows some of them are ir
images of aircraft
thunderfoot has demonstrated some are
birds and camera aperture artifacts
so what you're saying the government is
lying about aliens now yeah that's what
i was i was gonna say like i feel like
the government knows about
like the military intelligence would
probably have ways to check that
i don't think so i would think all right
we got two two-parter here from stephen
valdez ii
tim what is your advice concerning
cryptocurrency um i don't have any
advice for you
i'll tell you what i'm gonna do i love
it i think there's a combination
bitcoin to me is bitcoin is the only
truly decentralized
you know gold value system
everything else is a company you know
for the most part
like dogecoin is kind of decentralized
but it's a lot weaker it's it's
it's all right bitcoin is truly
decentralized deflationary no one can
take it over
they can try but there's people fighting
you know uh ethereum is basically like
buying a resource that a company owns
and controls so
but i like cryptocurrency um i'm gonna
be buying more of it
steven says lauren will we see an asian
president in our lifetime
i don't know i i would rather see a
competent president
personally that's where my interests lie
more so you're saying yes you want an
asian president
yeah uh yeah i don't know i don't really
care about stuff like that though
much all right asia yeah i don't know i
think
you know in our lifetimes how old are
you
i think so i got a good 50 60 years uh
clay chapman says tim if we get a video
to 100k
likes can we be rewarded with guest
schuon head all right here we go
everyone listening right now if we can
reach 100
000 likes and shuan had chooses to come
on the show
or if just shuan had chooses to come on
the show
then we'll have shoe on head because
she's already been invited and she just
doesn't want to come on the show i guess
so there you go uh get us to 100 000
likes anyway yeah let's go
tristan rosario says tim i'm a
conservative game designer
shout out my game our dilemma available
in early access on itch.io
where there's a link to my patreon i
also sent you an email titled
narrative designer for fps game where
you can see my work
right on cool don't need to know says
you're being shadow banned didn't get
notifications
couldn't find it on my subscribed list
had to go to your page to get it on here
which means
you should take the url and share it
with as many people as you can because
this is
that's the point also had you clicked
the bell button i want to know i know
you just
super chatted it's hard apparently
that's how you get the notifications no
but i mean it's it's kind of a roll of
the dice i have notifications on for
some channels but sometimes i won't get
them or i'll get them way later
even if it's alive i'll get them after
they're already off getting them way
later isn't always a bad thing
because they don't want to send it to
literally every single person at the
same time
then you get less views actually so they
delay and stagger it
but the system's imperfect i will say
it's a free marketing system
yeah it's pretty amazing it's free
marketing look if you if
so the people like who are telling me
this you chose to come to this show you
know when it is you know when it's live
could you imagine if people's tvs
automatically just like popped up tucker
carlson every day
they don't do that you have to choose to
watch tucker you have to choose to watch
this it is beneficial to us when youtube
recommends us though
all right darune albane says tim buy the
tesla power backup
store the external part till you get a
new building up and just charge from the
grid plus propane generator
if the propane generator is only for the
battery charging you will not need three
to four of them
you can only get them with solar panels
but the good news is
we are getting solar um we were trying
to wait until we got
uh um a better roof because we're gonna
redo the garage but
at this point with the power getting
knocked out the other day yeah
we'll just get the batteries thanks for
that super chat by the way
fine castle says nothing makes my day
like tim having one of my favorite
canadians on
love your content lauren speaking of
canadians will you ever interview tom
mcdonald
tom is has an open invite i've spoken
with him but
you know he's a big shot man it's like
come on he's busy yeah
he's a busy guy he's super famous i
would be turn i would be very very
grateful for him to come on this show
but uh
you know busy guy
west side powersports sedu parts says
tim you keep asking people to share this
video
but facebook has throttled my page so
bad i get little to no response despite
having 2 000 plus friends
i can't thank i can thank them though i
now spend little to no time on facebook
well you know
that same thing happened to me so weird
political pothead says stop being so
pessimistic look at independent hip hop
tom mcdonald up church adam calhoun
jelly roll struggle jennings plus music
via nfts
decentralization takes time yeah i'm
optimistic for that stuff you know
so maybe we'll see what happens maybe we
are on a good a good
track all right
bc says tim i think the letter written
to slate is real i worked with a guy who
intentionally dehydrated himself so he
wouldn't have to leave his office to use
the restroom during the work day
yikes okay so i
do this on road trips and while
traveling i have a tiny bla why am i
sharing this
this is good info yeah i don't know why
okay whatever
um i could believe that's not the same
though as
wearing a mess well no that's not the
same yeah it's different
they call it water fasting yeah weird
or dry fasting is what they call it yeah
yeah
all right dude that story about the guy
that wears a mask during sex is insane
does like he not realize other bodily
fluids are being exchanged
can you get sick that way though they
said originally yeah
all right mark walton says war of the
worlds broadcast really did scare a lot
of people
my father has told me that my
grandfather thought it was real they had
no way of knowing it was not
not a real news broadcast yeah no
internet sounds like rachel maddow yeah
just kidding rage no no you're right
actually
but that's kind of funny because i've
noticed there are a lot of like horror
movies now that take place during the
80s or 90s and i think the sole reason
is because cell phone and internet yeah
those two things
pretty much nip most horror plots in the
bud
let's see uh jordan fox says tim can you
make timcast.com bumper stickers i'll
display it on my vehicle to help spread
the word about your show keep it the
great work
yeah good idea there we go i like it
polymer says tim please do something
with freedom tunes with your fouchy
impersonation
having him spew all sorts of outlandish
nonsense about vampires and zombies etc
sheamus are you listening i i will i
will be dr fauci
for you for freedom tunes a droplet
remember that he said it might stop a
drop yeah
dewey mcnasty says i'm so glad we don't
have an idiot in the white house anymore
jk it's worse than ever
john marafa says question for lauren you
said you saw the biggest rat ever in new
york city so when did you meet bill de
blasio or was it andrew cuomo
[Laughter]
although i mean to get the actual
question i think cuomo is slimier than
de blasio
yeah especially with the ladies it seems
dewy mcnasty says could you imagine how
different the political lands
landscape would be if it were tulsi
versus donald i feel like it would still
be kind of crazy but the situation we're
in right now makes me pull my hair out
wtaf is going on
a lot too much garhant says lightfoot
will lose the lawsuit
do the interview and she will have to
eat a river of
detritus in the end in the interim
she'll have her crt views put in print
and visible to all
she'll lose her election maybe yeah but
she can do the interview
and he'll be alike so you're pushing
critical race theory at you know at this
level why are you doing that
i don't know next question
but i mean even interviews aside
campaign stuff aside i've got a thing
like if you're someone who's living in
chicago right now you see everything
that's happening
how could you vote for the same mayor at
the next election i don't understand
no idea it is weird we have a very
important question um the real hydro
says tim when will your frontal lobe
develop
i'm not sure hopefully soon you're in a
permanent flow state
but i will say there's something
tremendously scary
if i don't have a frontal lobe and have
been able to be this successful and you
haven't
oh snap i got you apparently that's how
you go into flow is you quiet your
frontal lobe
or you hit it don't develop oh yeah
people with head injuries
are going to float like have like flow
states yeah they're all crazy is that
the thing from the movie soul where they
like transport themselves to like the
afterlife
i don't know that's what they call it
jmac says my son is eight and he has to
help out
it's not a free ride my daughter two and
she's four too many worthless adults had
parents that did everything for them no
allowance for chores
that are expected either you want to
make money you got to do more than than
expected
amen you know you do you lock the fridge
and you put prices on everything oh my
gosh
wow like a little quarter slot yeah i
love it i don't know you should make
them buy it
so it's like your kid's like i want a
peanut butter sandwich like all right
this costs 75 cents
what have you done to earn it and then
all the chores can be worth certain
amounts
yeah that's fascinating and then the
best part is it's really easy to teach
socialism because then
when one sibling doesn't work at all you
take their money away and give it to
them and they start complaining about it
be like don't vote for socialists
there you go henry vallas says tim and
crew please wish my beautiful wife
rachel a happy
anniversary we are huge fans and love
you all
also look into hemp-based building
materials such as hemp crete yes
hempwool and hempwood
also hemp herd for chicken bedding happy
anniversary guys
happy anniversary rachel david salter
says tim
i love the show except when you say jiff
excellent i did want to
point its gift man the inventor the
inventor of it said it's just yeah
yeah but it's graphic it stands for
graphic the guy who invented it says
it's just
is it graphic interface is that what it
means interchange format interchange
form
and so you guys even know that you're
trying to tell me yeah yeah i do know
that's peanut butter i feel like
we're in a time warp right now didn't
this happen yes it's just
tim's wrong it's okay so the the guy who
invented it said
gif is it gif isn't it no he said it's
jeff
the guy who invented it yeah but richard
stallman said it's gnu
his software news it's gnu like the
animal that you know
and he invented it so he's he's correct
but gnu is pronounced new not gnu
he can call whatever he wants well he
can invent a file format that doesn't
mean he invents the english language
could you imagine people like being so
dumb they say something like
uh a magic giant was casting oh my gosh
sometimes there's a soft chain sometimes
there's a soft g
i give up let's go back to our super
chat yeah exactly what
anyway uh joshua leblanc says lauren
chen is the joke
oh god
he really did say go though he got you i
love it
jeffrey mccormin says g alfred g
okay question for ian what are your
thoughts on son sono luminescence
oh that oh gosh what is that what is
that oh
that is i know it's obviously something
that's glowing that's the luminescent
part
is it some sano with an n sonic
sonoluminescence
oh is that when they make use sound to
make light yeah it is
you can vibrate uh a substrate and and
create light in fact you can create
light out of the vacuum and then
create electrons out of light so you can
basically create
energy out of the vacuum that's crazy
all right let's see terry uh teremoto jr
says
think what we're seeing in society is a
spiritual great depression
lacking purpose and belonging we cling
to anything to make us feel good about
ourselves no matter how delusional it
might be yeah
people need to learn how to meditate
yeah i was just thinking that we should
take all these angry people
and just like bring him to like an
ancient yogi atop a mountain
and have him just like tell him what's
up yeah you experience nothing
that's best sometimes i tried the
hippies most hipster thing the other day
but it ended up being great it's this
sound chair experience so it's
you you go on a chair and it like
reclines so it's almost the zero g
position
and it vibrates in sync with like all
these ocean sound stuff
so it's to help people meditate who
can't shut off their minds
so it gives you something to focus on
like just the sound and the vibrations
and it's
actually really cool and i'm too like
all over the place to meditate by myself
but it was amazing how long did you do
it for i did it for like 30 minutes but
it's weird because i remember like i
couldn't get into it
and then i looked at the clock and i had
like 25 minutes left i was like oh it's
gonna take forever
and then two seconds later i looked and
i was done oh it's amazing what the heck
we're yeah i mean i it's almost like i
fell asleep but i wasn't sleeping it was
cool i had never been able to i guess
meditate successfully
it was cool these people think they can
get me they
think i've learned don't you think don't
you realize this i'm gonna read it
anyway
do it do it dead eye says tim your ads
on spotify are jarring
they need to be smoother like michael
knowles in his new book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
what michael knowles turned his promo
for his book into a meme dude that's how
he's going to sell so many books it is
the smartest thing ever yeah he is a
very intelligent fellow yes yeah
luke slivkoff says awesome to see lauren
on the show she was one of the first
political podcasts that i listened to
back when she was roaming millennial
great show i remember messing up your
name many times luke slifkoff
where where where were you roaming too
oh well it was because i had moved
around so much
oh okay previously yeah i used to love
robbie millennial oh thank you
but that show got cancelled and replaced
by the lauren chencho yes
yeah like don lemon right wasn't that
like what levin did yeah he canceled not
cancelled
oh yeah you saw that where you like
tried to like fake
quit quit yeah yeah what was that what
happened with roaming millennials you
just decide one day to start using your
own name and
yeah i mean like i essentially started
doing like more in-person stuff and like
doing more newsy stuff and then it got
weird trying to
like explain what that is pigeon speaks
yeah and like i remember like i went on
the first time i was ever on like fox
and friends they like i
accidentally doxed me anyway like live
on air
this is interesting paul wallace says it
happens gradually and then suddenly
hemingway's character was talking about
bankruptcy but it's true about many
other things as well very true
yeah i think we're definitely at the
point in the societal
crisis that any day really could be the
switch
where it goes full you know full bore
any kind of line graph
it looks like it's going up in a
straight line but if you if you zoom in
you'll see it's going like this
up down up down but it's constantly
going up slowly but when you zoom out it
looks like a fluid upward pattern
10 years we'll close up on this 10 years
ago if you said to me
that the country would collapse i'd be
like no way
yeah yeah if if someone came to me and
said it'll be next tuesday i'd be like
gradually and then suddenly yeah maybe
yeah i mean i'm actually at a point now
where i believe it
that's scary amanda dilts says has
anyone on the show read the sword of
truth series by terry goodkind
if not please give it a read it shows
what happens when communism
comes up comes up against the free
choice
and how one person can make change yeah
cool
euphoric break says under the great
reset you will live in pods in smart
cities under 24 7 365 surveillance
you will be lucky to get bugs in your
died of pills vans
you will be a serf living in a
neo-feudalistic system with zero rights
you might not me i'm the special one of
course
it'll never happen to me exactly these
people are like the people who get bit
in zombie movies and don't tell anyone
because they think they're the special
one who's not gonna get sick
dude that's the most annoying thing if i
was if i was in a zombie apocalypse and
i got bit
i'd just be like guys sorry yeah oh my
gosh
yeah of course that'd be a hard scene to
watch i can't stand i had to cut off my
arm first if it was bit on the arms yeah
totally yeah just i'd be like
that would be great i got one of them
but it's too late
oh yeah you can't i mean it's just
not real life that you get bit and then
like a few minutes you turn to his eye
is that rabies what how long does that
take
a month oh
zombie movie though where something with
like a slower lead up time where it
takes longer to fester
maybe like a like there's like a minor
virus that people get
yeah and no one really cares about it
and then all of a sudden like a it's
like
a second phase and then people just
start like
like if you've ever played plague inc
you know you gotta put really high
virility but low lethality to start off
with
yeah and then turn it up yep and then
like once the movie ends
it like zooms out and then it goes
through a screen and there's like a
seven-year-old kid just like
that would be great like men in black oh
man yeah
goldilocks says the guy you had on
yesterday or tuesday was an idiot when
it comes to world war ii history
britain france and america leaving
leaving germany alone was not an option
then germany attacked france first
documents found post-war showed plans
for a u.s mainland invasion
you know france actually did invade
germany in 1939
they did a failed invasion uh didn't
didn't go very well for them
jeez but i mean obviously germany
jason jason freeman says ian any idea
what carbon footprint is caused by data
mining and tracking bots can we save the
planet by banning advertisers and data
collection
um i don't know what what amount of
carbon footprint is made by that but i
i tend to take the route of rather than
reduce the amount of carbon emissions
that we withdraw the carbon from
the atmosphere and reuse it carbon
captures yeah yeah deposited onto
like palladium to create graphene and
things like that i have a really good
question
igloo king says tim quote you're not
going to vote your way out of this why
would a
tyrant give your freedoms back they
won't the actual quote i said is why
would oregon give up their serfs
so the people of oregon voted they want
to join idaho
as far as i'm concerned it's done the
people have
rescinded their consent to oregon and
they want to go to idaho if idaho
approves i say
do it um but they're not going to
oregon's not going to give up their
service then he says also tim
i do not condone violence and i do not
call for people taking up arms what to
do
it's really easy i said it over and over
and over again we are in fourth and
fifth generational warfare
you win by gaining control of
institutions by working there
by building culture by sharing youtube
videos
so that the predominant view shifts in
the culture
and then you don't win back in the day
when there's no communication
war was you marched in and demanded it
and if they didn't then you had weapons
today's day and age is you convince
people you propagandize
you share information and the left does
all of that in spades so how do you win
you don't storm the capital because
that's the biggest weapon
most people not paying attention are
shocked and scared by that well a lot of
them probably don't care
but a lot of people view it as the
apocalypse you can see them
propagandizing
that's how they win and the cops aren't
helping anybody they're just doing what
they're told
so you have to build culture and be
peaceful resourceful and persuasive
there you go jeff ross says would you
have considered
would you consider having donut operator
on the show
he's an ex-cop turned youtuber that i
think would be good content and yes
absolutely we would
standing invite i'm telling you guys
uh dude x01 says charles hoskinson
founder of cardano and eth said that he
would come
on tim cast if he was invited on twitter
today he was invited by lydia on twitter
he was
twice yeah several times i'd love to
have him
lydia does all the booking so indeed
there you go
dj madero says star trek ds9 episode in
the pale moonlight
best defines what a man will do if he
believes the ends justify the means
it's a dangerous ideology if you would
ask me
all right alexander ali says captain
america said we don't trade lot trade
lives
but vision and half the population died
anyways you can poke holes in either
philosophy
but that's only because he lost but i
guess a utilitarian would argue that
i mean trying to save everyone with like
refusing to acknowledge the fact that
there will be losses and
taking the the initiative to minimize
those losses
will result in overall more people being
hurt regardless of how much you may try
ac 130 says great king of the hill
episode about the trolley problem
hank is left with the decision to open
the floodgates or destroy other homes
and is hated after
that's why people don't people just
don't want to have the decision leave me
out of it
i want to be responsible people need to
learn to be responsible though
yeah because making no decision is a
decision that's a good way of looking at
it
said all right we'll do a few more
let's see bl 42 jd
cool hearing ian say gnu what distro do
you use ian
uh i currently don't i use windows
whoa um i've never i've never used gano
but i've studied a lot of richard
stallman i have a lot of respect for the
guy i'm sad that he went through the
whole cancel culture thing
um you know i think his text was kind of
i don't know did you guys are you
familiar with richard stallman what did
he built the gnu
uh system the free software kind of
created the free software movement and
then he
wrote something about epstein and like
supporting people that went there i
don't know
and then mit fired him but it's
unfortunate because he's kind of like
the yoda of computer code oh man here's
a good
good one oh omg just remembered i was
listening to you and my dad recognized
your voice and said to me
is that the hat guy
it is that guy that's me
kayla sherrard says a modern trolley
problem my professor posed
is the algorithms in self-driving cars
to prevent accidents would we avoid
crashes by crashing into pedestrians
might demographics come into play with
time well that's what people are
already asserting with ai that it is
racist
because apparently more black people
have been
run over or something yeah i'm not sure
what they're thinking there but yeah
mike sullivan says love lauren's
response about the trolley five
cancers to society and one with the cure
truly no malarkey
all right all right and by the way
malarkey is our podcast
oh i like that yeah oh really yeah no
malarkey it's a
joe biden fan podcast no no it's there's
no malarkey that would be a lot of
molarity
oh yes yes yes much malarkey mucho
malarkey spanish language anti-biden
podcast
no pro biden sorry mucho molecules
all right aaron bortner says you guys
should come to gettysburg pa area
nice place and tim if you come up that
far i'll take you to a nice cement skate
park in york free
cool we should um search for ghosts and
gettysburg oh my gosh if you ever want
to do a ghost hunting series
i just bought some emf detectors because
we're going to be doing this paranormal
show
but i must stress there is no evidence
or
anything indicating emf has anything to
do with it it could be sub-atomic
vibration imagine i'm curious what it is
imagine like
a dude in the 1800s just like walking
around with some kind of like
magnifying glass looking at things
saying like i'm going to use this device
which allows us to see
smaller things and like you'd by today's
standards you'd be like what are you
doing
yeah so in like 100 years they're going
to look back and these people were so
i'm looking for well i mean like
infrared stuff they say cold spots or i
don't know
yeah we can get night vision goggles
yeah that'd be cool
all right let's see we'll do uh we'll do
uh one more we'll do two more
ming no sullivan says summer coming up
when will you be selling fauci
flip-flops we won't because i don't have
the rights to his likeness
get it though flip yeah that's good yeah
flip flops
here's here's the the last we'll do one
more deadeye says
michael knowles is smart with his
marketing campaign but don't forget
about michael mouse's new book the
anarchist handbook available now
you guys go buy those books make them
number one on amazon so that when
regular people go on amazon they see
those books
cultural enforcement that's right that's
cool what's anarchists handbook about
are you guys
familiar i mean other than anarchy the
obvious but
it's uh it's about michael malus's
handbook for
anarchism yeah so he's basically
breaking down what is anarchy
he goes to history i can ask him about
it yeah he talks about uh what's her
face
emma goldman is their name i think so
and then that guy that that cute guy he
was talking about on the show and like
yeah
that's good-looking that's right all
right hey thanks for hanging out
everybody go to facebook.com
tim cast irl and follow like the page
and share the videos because we are
going to leverage the facebook network
to get people to join our website
timcast.com
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a bonus segment coming up
and that's where we say the things
youtube gets mad at us for and we swear
a whole lot
and uh you can follow us on instagram as
well at timcast irl you can follow me
at timcast basically everywhere we do
the show monday through friday live at
8pm so we're always around give us a
good review lauren you want to shout out
your show
sure so uh you can find me like i said
youtube odyssey rumble
bit shoot lauren chen on there i host a
weekly podcast with my friend marie
oakes who is also a journalist for the
westphalian times it is called no
malarkey i think our next episode we've
already filmed it should be going up
tomorrow and i don't have a patreon so
as always if you do want to support my
videos you can head on over to
clearlypure.com
it's my family's bath and body company
we're actually having a father's day
sale right now
uh let's see if it's like a sliding
thing so if you buy
like a hundred dollars worth of stuff
use the code
20 get 20 off and if you buy 50 worth of
stuff use the code dad 10
get 10 off so yeah that's what i have
instead of a pay wall so
clearly pure p-u-r yeah so
c-l-e-a-r-l-y-p-u-r dot-com and that
yeah that helps keep the videos going
really good material you brought some
soap last time i
loved it i had the salt soap i was oh it
just feels so good on my face
thanks yeah i like i bring soap now when
i travel i'm using my mom's new lime
soap it's really good
and it's also hard to travel with solid
soap i've learned because it's you have
to dry it but yeah hey you guys can also
follow me in crossland.net and follow me
on social media ian crossland also i've
got some music online um
itunes amazon music things like that so
if you want to check it out check it out
and feel free to
are more than welcome downl follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter as i try to
have more followers and sour patch kids
we will see you at timcast.com in the
exclusive
members only bonus segment with lauren
coming up around 11 p.m thanks for
hanging out we'll see you then bye guys
you